If you look at pictures from these
Middle Eastern nations, you will be
amazed. If you look at a 1920s picture,
you'll think you're looking at Europe.
>> There feels like a sense of a warning
that you're giving the West about Islam
that we're not taking it seriously
enough.
>> Most of what we call the Muslim world,
which again, North Africa, the Middle
East, but all into Asia, the vast
majority of that land was taken by
conquest. So now you fast forward to
today and your average Westerner
European has no idea about this. You
have to understand who and what you're
bringing in. Who's the enemy? Everyone.
Who's not a Muslim? Okay, are there
Christians who are nominal Christians
who want to engage in violence and Yeah,
of course. Can Islam [music] have an
enlightenment and truly reform itself?
You or Sam Harris, Muslims don't care
what you think.
If you had to put forward a thesis about
how the West should think about Islam,
what would it be? The thesis would be
that Islam is
not just another religion, it's an
entire coherent political system. A lot
of people are approaching Sharia, which
is usually loosely translated as Islamic
law.
And they're they have no problem
condemning it, a lot of Americans, you
know, Greg Abbott, Trump. Abbott said
like there's no room for Sharia in in
Texas, for example. And that's all well
and good, but I think as people start
learning, well, guess what? Sharia and
Islam are inherently the same. You know,
one I call one Islam the descriptive
name of the religion. And Sharia is the
prescriptive application.
So that's I guess that would be my
ultimate thesis, which is you know, you
maybe you see what Sharia is, maybe you
don't like it, maybe you find it
incompatible with the West, but guess
what? That's not just some weird
accretion that some radicals do. That is
Islam.
All right, so when I'm reading the stuff
you write, when I hear you talk on the
internet, there feels like a sense of a
warning that you're giving the West
about Islam that we're not taking it
seriously enough. Something along those
lines. Does that feel fair? From the
very beginning of Islam in the 7th
century, after Muhammad dies and the
Arabians consolidated under the banner
of Islam, they go on the jihad,
according to Islamic teaching.
And in one century, from the death of
Muhammad, 632 to 732, they literally
have conquered three quarters of the
Christian world, which most people have
no idea about, okay? When people hear of
countries like Egypt and Syria or
Turkey, they just have in their mind
this vague idea that they were always
either Muslim or kind of Eastern. Yeah.
No, they were actually, if you went in
the 7th century, that was Christianity
was more ingrained in Egypt, in Turkey,
in Syria, in Morocco, Mauritania, and in
Tunisia, you know, the father of Western
theology, Augustine, he's from Tunisia.
He's a North African, he was a Berber.
Okay? And most of the the early fathers
were Egyptians and Syrians and so forth.
And you had five seas, five major
centers. One was Rome, the other four,
Alexandria, Antioch, Jerusalem, and
Constantinople, all got conquered by
Islam. So it was a long constant war
that went on literally for over a
millennium, okay? Century after century.
Whenever Muslims could, obviously there
were times when it was an ebb and flow
and due to the vicissitudes of
circumstances and Muslims weren't strong
enough, they wouldn't attack, but
>> [snorts]
>> any such time that they were strong,
they conquered. So I just told you, I
gave you the date 732, one century,
because that's the Battle of Tours and
that's where Islam is finally stopped in
the center of France. Spain has now been
conquered, all of North Africa has been
conquered.
>> [snorts]
>> The greater Middle East has been
conquered and then later Turkey gets
conquered, which is one of the most
ancient Christian regions, that's where
St. Paul sent many of his letters, it
features in the Book of Revelation.
There was a long constant war and
annexation of Christian territories by
Islam historically, just as a fact. And
why did they do it? So even if you find
a historian who is willing to talk about
this, they'll give them their national
names, okay? They'll talk about the Arab
conquest, they'll talk about the the
Moors in Spain, they'll talk about the
Turks and they'll talk about the Tatars
and the Mongols, they'll call them
Saracens.
And when you hear it that way, as I did
in college,
you're prone to just think, okay, these
are different warring groups, just like
in Europe, French and the English are
warring. It's not there's no ideological
component necessarily.
But if you dig into the sources as I
have, the primary sources, including
from the Muslim sources, they see
themselves not necessarily as Turks or
Arabs, but as Muslims first and
foremost.
And their rationale for war on whoever,
let's say Christians, is you're an
infidel. And you know, that's the rule
of Islam and we have to attack you and
give you the three choices, convert,
die, or pay tribute and be a second
class citizen, etc., etc. So my point is
it was a long constant massive war that
went on, that swallowed up most of the
Christian West, okay? You know, we call
it the West because it's west of what?
Well, west it it was when we think of
the West, it now has its own kind of
connotation. But historically, in the
medieval era, it was it was west because
it was the westernmost portion of
Christianity that didn't get conquered.
Hmm. Okay, it was the final appendage,
Europe.
And there was a constant warfare,
constant struggle that went on, you
know, Islamic pirates would go as far as
Iceland in the 16th century for raids
and they would come back with loads of
slaves. America's first war, most people
are unaware, as a nation following
independence from Britain, was with
Muslims who were again again using the
same logic. And it's interesting because
it comes out in the writings of Thomas
Jefferson,
um who you know, this paragon of
enlightenment who had of course
obviously forgotten about those Muslims
and didn't really understand what was
going on, but
they were enslaving American sailors in
their vessels, they would raid them,
pirates, Muslim pirates from Barbary.
And Adams, John Adams and Jefferson met
with one of the ambassadors from Barbary
and basically and we have the existing
letter
where where Jefferson wrote a letter to
Congress saying what happened in the
meeting. And he says, we told him, look,
can't we just be friends? We have
nothing against you. You can do your
religion and let's let's engage in
trade, let's help each other. And then
Jefferson writes, and the man answered
us and said, it's in our Quran, you're
the enemy, you're the infidel, we must
wage war on you, etc., etc., okay?
So I tell you all that by way to answer
your question about the warning, okay?
So this has been going on for
over a millennium. This being we are
ideologically driven, we are going to
wage warfare to conquer the infidel.
>> Right. And we've have conquered. Most of
what we call the Muslim world, which
again, North Africa, the Middle East,
but all into Asia, okay? And in
sub-Saharan Africa, the vast majority of
that land was taken by conquest. So I
mentioned what was taken from
Christians, Iran was the Zoroastrian
great civilization that was conquered.
The Pakistan, okay, which land of the
pure, well, those are just Hindus who
finally were conquered and converted to
Islam, okay? Even in Indonesia, there's
this sort of story about no, no, didn't
spread through violence. There was
actually a lot of coercion once Muslims
grew in numbers. Um so so that's the
warning. So now you fast forward to
today and your average Westerner
European has no idea about this.
What they know is colonialism and you
know, evil Europeans. And now we're
going to make it up for them. I mean,
that's the logic in the UK, for example,
that's why it's flooded with Pakistanis
because
we're making up for our sins in
colonizing their lands and we're
bringing them here. That kind of logic.
>> And to you that's patently ridiculous.
It's patently ridiculous because, okay,
uh
you have to understand what you who and
what you're bringing in. And the Okay,
so now you've brought in, let's say the
UK and the really big ones, UK, Germany,
and France,
but also Sweden,
you know, and the numbers of Muslims are
growing in Italy, Spain just gave a
blanket acceptance of like a million
migrants, which is kind of insane.
Spain went through 800 years of war to
evict Muslims, okay? The Reconquista,
literally. Because they couldn't get
along and now they're bringing them. So
it just shows you the massive disconnect
between
the Western world with for with its
history
>> [snorts]
>> and the Muslim world, like I said, is
continuity. So okay, when Muslims come
to Europe, so just to explain to you
some ideas,
according to Islamic rule, Islamic law,
Sharia, Muslims are forbidden from
voluntarily migrating to live under
non-Muslim rule, infidel rule. You have
to live in the lands of Sharia, where
Islam
Islam is uh
dominates, okay? Why would you go live
with the enemy? Because the non-Muslim
>> That Oh, yeah, that's stated.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. But now there's caveats, okay?
Which I'll get to. So that I mean, but
that is the normal state of affairs.
They're the enemy.
We're the Muslims. The Quran is full of
this whole doctrine, which it's in
Arabic, it's called al-wala' wal-bara',
which means Muslims must only help,
befriend, like, side with, and be loyal
to Muslims of the ummah. Well, ummah
basically means the supranational
Islamic community that transcends race,
you know, language, ethnicity,
and geography.
And they must have hatred for the
non-Muslim. And when and whenever they
can, they must wage war and try to
subjugate them, okay? That is a legit
doctrine straight out of the Quran. I've
written a lot about it. I can give you
some verses if you want.
But so that's the driving doctrine that
propelled the historic jihad. It still
exists. Muslims still think this way. So
then you bring masses of them into
Europe. I mentioned the main countries,
England and UK and whatnot.
And if you look there, you got there's a
lot of problems, okay? I mean, nobody's
going to argue that if you want to be
honest. Of course, there are certain
people want to put their head in the
sand and say, no, no, everything's fine,
but no, there's massive problems. You
probably heard of this Restore Britain
new party that came out. I mean, there's
a reason why people and if you hear the
words of what he's saying, uh I think
his last name is Lowe, um you know, it's
it's on the one hand it's refreshing
because it's basically what everyone
there is thinking.
You know, on the other hand, it's like I
can't you never would have imagined
someone talking that way a decade ago.
But why is he? Because it's a reflection
of the
>> a flag for people. So, some people that
are watching this right now, their base
assumption is going to be uh
Rupert Lowe is a wild bigot. Uh
you are giving this cuz you've got some
axe to grind around bigotry and we'll
get to growing up as an Egyptian
Christian and what that means and all of
that. Um but
I want to So, I wanted to get all of
that out on the table so the people
understand what the sort of core thesis
is, what you're worried about, that
there's all this historical continuity.
Um Muslims are driven by a core
doctrine. That core doctrine says that
you should be going in and conquering um
based on the religious doctrine. We've
got people now going into these
countries, uh call it immigration
through conquest. You didn't say that,
but I know your work I'm familiar enough
that I know that that's a a thing on the
table. Okay. Now, I want to back up and
I want to walk through what the
foundational beliefs are that you have
that lead you to that because I want the
people watching this to be able to draw
a well-informed conclusion as to whether
this is just bigotry or whether there
really is a reason to be concerned about
this.
Um so
how did you grow up? Your parents are uh
immigrants from Egypt, right? Uh but
they're not Muslim. So, give me that
background, what that was like, and most
importantly, how it informs your views.
Okay.
So, my um correct, I was born here and
my parents immigrated from Egypt. Um
they're what's called Coptic Christians,
okay? And the word Coptic is uh
basically a corruption of the Greek word
Aigyptos, which is where we get our
English Egyptian. It's Aigyptos. And so,
when the Arabs invaded and they met the
Aigyptos, they just called them Gypt.
They dropped the first and last
syllables, and Gypt eventually found its
way to us as Copts, okay? So,
but now it means, you know, the
indigenous inhabitants of Egypt
pre-Islam who still exist in minorities
and are Christians because, like I was
telling you, those countries were still
Christian when the when the Arabs
invaded them. Egypt was conquered around
641 AD.
Okay, so
now here's the thing, and I know where
you're going with this cuz people have
said this to me before, which is, "Oh,
you you it's because you're a Christian
and you feel like Muslims took over your
country and you have an axe to grind."
And I've heard that before.
Now, here's the the the truth that most
people don't understand. And if you find
an Egyptian or a Copt from Egypt, most
of them are going to tell you, "Yeah."
Which is actually a lot of Coptic
Christians don't even like what I'm
saying and would not agree with me. And
they and they like their they'll tell
you, "All my friends are all Muslims.
You're a hate-monger. What what are you
doing?" And I would actually argue my
parents would have been at least
neutral. Yeah, they weren't like, "Oh,
we love Muslims." But they wouldn't have
said, you know, "Oh, yeah, Muslims are
all monsters or evil." So, I I I can
honestly say that that the only thing
that my own personal background made a
might have done is it drew interest in
the question in the first place. My main
interest is history. I studied history.
That's what I majored in in history. And
so, it was natural, of course, for me to
gravitate to those topics that are part
of who I am, okay? So, yeah, okay, I'm a
Copt, I'm Christian, Muslims, but it's
So, that's why my first thesis was, for
example, about the first military
conflict between Muslims and Christians
because I was involved in military
history at the time.
So, I don't think that you know, my my
if anything, my background, if you
really dig into it, and you know,
there's this theory that, "Oh, yeah,
every Christian from the Islamic world
hates Muslims and they're being
persecuted." And that's not even true. I
mean,
that's one of the topics I'm expert in.
I have a another book on the persecution
of Christians. And we can talk about
that, but um most Christians would
actually, because it's a cultural thing,
a lot of Christians from the Middle East
are culturally like Muslims. So, if you
put a if you put an American Christian
and a Coptic Christian and an Egyptian
Muslim, the Coptic Christian and the
Muslim are going to be best friends.
Because culturally they see things eye
to eye.
So, I tell you all this, okay, so you
understand that no, that's not in any
way
Christians are not born and bred with
this, "Oh, those Muslims, we can't wait
till we get away from them." Okay, now
obviously there's some who did
experience persecution in the modern
era, and it's getting worse now, but
like let's say in my parents' day, it
wasn't that bad at all. You know, the
the Muslims were were were this is let's
say my parents were born in the '40s.
You know, so they're growing up in the
'60s. If Muslims in Egypt at that time
were nowhere near as radical as today.
And even today, a lot of them are not
radical.
And so, uh again, I'm just telling you
all this that just to tell you that that
is if anything, that should have
moderated my views. If we know that
Muslims and Christians can live side by
side and not end up having animosity
towards each other, um how is that
consistent with your view that there's
this pattern that repeats through
history, and so it's just sort of
inevitable, and if you're not careful,
it's going to happen again? Cuz that
tells me at least for one period,
everybody was fine living together. My
ultimate point is the religion of Islam
as it is as it is understood, written
down, documented, black and white in the
Quran, codified by the ulama or the
the clerics, okay?
Is is an intolerant and violent creed
that is uh incompatible with the West.
That's my message, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> Now, what happens
>> [laughter]
>> inevitably, and we're having it right
now, and I'm glad we are cuz it's
important, is all of a sudden now we
conflate the religion with the people.
Okay? And with every religion,
Christianity, Judaism, whatever, you
have teachings, and then you have people
who are to varying degrees associated
with the teaching, okay?
Uh we can look at Let's just look at
Okay, look at Judaism, right? You have
the actual
Orthodox Jews, and then you have I think
they're called the the Reformed or or um
I don't know. Liberal Jews, okay?
Okay, but they're all Jews.
And even the I think they're called
Reformed Jews,
uh who are like liberal Jews, uh you
know, they'll tell you, "Well, I'm I
believe this, but the Orthodox believe
something else." Okay? So,
but as it happens, the Orthodox, I'm
sure, are much closer to Judaism. And as
it happens, the radicals
>> As written, you mean?
>> As written, yeah. They're being
more consistent They're being more loyal
or adherent to the actual text and the
traditions and the history.
Now, the same thing with Islam. So, as I
described to you Islam, it is what it
is. It's violent, it's intolerant. It's
not out to live in coexistence. It's
it's out to become supreme, all right?
Now, the Muslims within Islam, you know,
what are there? Almost 2 billion people.
You're going to have some who think
that's great and who love it and who
want to activate it and who want to be
part of that. You're going to find some
who don't even know about it, who don't
care, just like the many nominal
Christians in the West who say, "I'm a
Christian," but what do they even know
about Christianity, right? You So,
you're going to have Muslims like that.
You're going to have Muslims who even
know what's what's that there's bad
stuff, but they're not going to they're
not going to live with it. They're going
to
There's going to be Muslims who know the
bad stuff, and they agree to it, but
they're not going to commit to it, not
yet, because it's the
the situation's not opportune.
So, I guess my point is I have I've
going back to my background and all
that, I've I've objectively studied
>> [snorts]
>> Islam. I know the I know the the
languages, the original languages. It's
been my academic background. I've
written books.
And what I'm telling you is not coming
from I'm a bitter
Copt with an axe to grind. It's coming
If anything, that should have tempered
me. Most of the Copts I know actually
don't like what I'm doing. You know,
"You're being a troublemaker. People
live in peace." Okay? So, to go back to
that, well, are they living in peace or
not? Well,
who's doing what? Some Christians in
Egypt and in Middle Eastern countries
get uh persecuted. Some get killed. Some
have uh Muslim neighbors who they get
along with. What will help us is to
break these down into
uh some chunks. So, the first thing is
what I'm hearing you say,
like any religion, some people are way
into it, some aren't.
Um hiding in there is a belief then that
even if you have the vast majority that
are call them secul
It doesn't take a large number of people
that are um Orthodox. I don't think
Muslims use that word, but that idea,
very strict, by the book, uh to create a
problem. And the ideology that's hiding
in the more um hardline Orthodox, we'd
say radical, but I want to stay away
from that kind of language,
that they're really tied to the word of
the Quran, the Hadith, the
interpretations. You'll have to walk us
through that, but
so, for now, I'll ask the audience to
accept that you have a core belief that
says it does not require a large number
of people to be a problem for there to
be a problem. So, you you've been very
clear about separating the people from
the religion. So, now walk us through
what are You've said a bunch of them,
but like sort of in passing, going
quickly.
Walk me through what is the doctrine of
Islam that becomes problematic for a
hardliner who's like, "But it says right
here to do this
>> Okay. There are actually three.
The first one I touched on is the second
one I'll mention briefly cuz it's the
most popular, which is jihad. Okay, that
is a doctrine. It's it's it's okay,
which is
there's Quranic verses, it's the life of
Muhammad, it's the example of the
caliphates, it's the example of the
sultanates, whether they're Arabs or or
Turks.
>> people will have heard the word, but
what is it actually, yeah? Okay, so it's
very interesting, actually. Jihad is
the old Orientalists, the original
translators, Europeans,
they would translate it as holy war. And
that's fair, you know, because when you
come across a foreign word, you can
either give it its most literal meaning
or you want to give it the connotation
that the Arab mind hears. And holy war
is exactly what it would mean, all
right? Now, what's funny and what it is
what it was historically is Muslims are
obligated to engage in holy war, which
is not just war, it's divine. Allah's
behind you. If you die, you you reach
the highest levels of paradise. So,
that's why it's holy.
And
who's the who's the enemy? Everyone
who's not a Muslim because we have to we
have to control their lands and we have
to rule them, all right? Is it ever
expressly said why? Like why do we have
to control, invade, conquer?
>> I'll answer it this way. Let's go to the
first really problematic doctrine.
Okay, what so jihad is the manifestation
of what I'm going to talk about. Now,
the first which I would call the first
premise doctrine which I've touched on
and it'll answer your question.
>> [snorts]
>> And it's the one in Arabic it's called
al-wala' wal-bara' and it's based on
numerous verses in the Quran and it's
basically okay.
>> Sorry, really fast. I think people
should know you speak Arabic as a first
language. Uh yeah, I was born here. So,
I I don't know. I I'm bilingual.
>> you spoke Arabic with your parents.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, with my
>> reading um direct sources. You've read
the Quran in Arabic.
>> Yes. Got it. Okay. Just making sure
people know that. Yeah, okay. So, this
doctrine
which is unwavering even, you know, with
chat GPT and AI which I think tend to be
politically correct. I put them on the
spot and I asked them about this
doctrine and they're like, yeah, this is
a legit doctrine. This is
>> And what sorry, what's the doctrine
exactly? So, it's called al-wala'
wal-bara' in Arabic and it can be
translated it's like a dichotomy. It
could be I used to translate it as
loyalty and enmity. Uh-huh. And a lot of
Muslims I've seen they
>> enmity is what? Love or hate? I actually
don't know. Well, so a lot of Muslims
simplify it by translating it as love
and hate. Okay.
>> I used to go with loyalty and enmity.
You can translate those words in
different ways. So, walat means to
befriend, to be allied to, to love, to
help. But as the opposite, it's the
disavow, have nothing to do with and
hate, okay?
And you are supposed to have the former,
the the
alliance and befriend to Muslims only,
okay? They are your brothers. And like I
said, it doesn't matter if they're
different races or cultures, you're all
Muslims.
You're supposed to have the second, the
hatred and the disavowal and the
renunciation of everyone who's not a
Muslim, okay? This is an ironclad
doctrine.
And it's not just disavowal. I mentioned
hatred. Quran 64 this is one of the most
problematic verses that very few people
know. 60 as in sura 60 ayah or verse
four.
It basically says, you have a good
example in Ibrahim, okay, who's the
who's the Abraham, okay, the Genesis
Abraham figure because of course Islam
appropriates all the biblical figures
and gives them different names or and
different roles. So, in Genesis Abraham
God calls him from the land of Ur and he
leaves and that's basically what we
know. In the Islamic rendering
before he leaves he tell his he tells
his kinsmen,
hatred and enmity will exist between you
and me or you and us Muslims because
he's a Muslim until you believe in Allah
alone. And then that verse says, and he
is a good example for you Muslims. This
is how you should feel towards
non-Muslims. And then there's all sorts
of examples of some of the pious Muslims
that were befriended with Muhammad
including the first caliph and the
second caliph. They fought and killed
their relatives and that's good. Allah
likes that because it shows their
loyalty is to the ummah and the Muslims
not their
and there's a verse that says and you
know, even if they're your fathers or
your brothers or whoever you can't be
loyal or befriend them because they're
infidels. And I have a video which I
translated like 15 years ago of an
Egyptian cleric
talking in Arabic and he's talking about
this very doctrine
and he mentions how
you know, Muslims can Muslim men can
marry people of the book which means
Christians and Jewish women.
But he says, but you have to hate them
and you have to let them know you hate
them. And you can have sex with them and
enjoy them, but you know, as long as the
hatred is in your heart, okay? So, this
is a teaching. Now, But is that just
some wacko or
>> It's in the Quran. I mean, you can say
he's a wacko who was clear you know,
that some of the even Muslims were very
like, are you sure? And he's like, well,
what do you want to do? There it is. And
he mentioned the verse that I told you
and others. [clears throat]
Um so, that's you know, that's the
problem. Now,
I'm telling you all this because I told
you there's three doctrines. So, the
first one this is the first one. It's
basically
>> hate non-Muslims.
>> Yeah, and they're loyal to fellow
Muslims. And so,
what Muhammad did I always say this is
his genius if you will is that he took
the the tribal mores of his society, 7th
century Arabia which is ultra
tribalistic,
but [snorts] he re-articulated them
through a theological paradigm. So, now
it's not just it's not normal tribalism
me and my family against yours. It's the
ummah it's the it's the Muslims versus
the rest of the world. The rest of the
world is the other, the non-tribe. And
just like it was in Arabia in the 7th
century, the non-tribe member is someone
who you can kill and enslave and do
whatever you want to.
Okay, so that became the doctrine and I
was telling you earlier that you Muslims
are not permitted to
migrate voluntarily and live under
Islamic non-Islamic authority, okay?
Because you're not supposed to be loyal
to them. How can you give allegiance?
The caveat is and this goes back so
we've we've dealt with the first one,
the loyalty and enmity and now we're
talking about jihad again.
And the caveat is okay, you can go to
these European countries and as long as
you are in one way or the other involved
in jihad on behalf of Islam.
Now, the historic manifestation which I
mentioned is of jihad is violent
warfare, okay? This is why they called
it they translated it as holy war. But
the this is what I find funny. A lot of
the apologists today will tell you, no,
no, holy war is wrong cuz the words
jihad really means to struggle and to
strive.
Which is true, but that actually makes
it even more problematic or makes it
even more dangerous and it underscores
what's going on. That is the literal
meaning of the word. You are supposed to
struggle or and strive on behalf of
Islam.
Historically that meant war cuz nobody
was going to just give in to you unless
you force them.
So, now they've they Muslim clerics have
articulated a number of jihads,
struggles,
that are not militant or physical. They
call them and they give them different
names. I'm I'm going to I'm just
translating them in my head. There's the
jihad of the tongue, the jihad of the
pen, the jihad of money, the baby jihad.
And all of these Muslims who if you
migrate to the West are expected to be
engaged in this because that is how
you're still a good Muslim. If you're
just going to the West because you want
a good life, well, okay, you're a
traitor, you're not a real Muslim. So,
but if you're doing these jihad of the
pen and the tongue means I'm somehow
engaged in propaganda on behalf of
Islam. I'm trying to demoralize
Westerners. I'm trying to I'm doing
what's called dawah. I'm preaching
Islam, okay? I'm making Islam look good.
Jihad of the money of course is I'm a
rich Saudi and I just spend millions to
help further whatever Islamist jihadist
causes.
And the baby jihad this is the really
dangerous one in in many ways in Europe
is the Muslims are encouraged to be as
fertile as possible and overwhelm the
you know, Europe. They literally have
said that. I mean, there's clerics on
videos saying your job is go there and
have as many babies as you want. And
[snorts] you go to Europe right now in
many of the major capitals the number
one newborn baby name is Muhammad. Okay,
so
that is so now so I'm trying to show you
the continuity of what had gone on
historically and
>> Really fast though because I there's one
piece that is missing in all this. So,
you use a word I could follow all of
your logic, but you use a word that at
least with the items you put on the
table does not yet make sense to me
which is the most dangerous thing is
and the most dangerous thing is that
they're basically outbreeding. They're
going to have more kids.
>> fundamental the
on a philosophical level the most
dangerous thing is this is a hostile
element or demographic that is trying to
take over whichever way. Yeah, okay. So,
let me let me push deeper into this
really fast and you can tell me if I'm
getting this wrong. So, your worldview
has internal consistency if I believe
the following. So,
for that to be dangerous there has to be
some part and
I know the punchline I think of what
you're going to say because I've studied
you so closely, but there's this element
of okay, this is high risk because they
act one way when they're weak and they
act another way when they're strong. And
so, the reason I think you have to walk
us through now if this actually is what
you're saying, uh through why you
believe it is erroneous to call this a
religion of peace even though in the
Quran itself there are overtures to
peace, to non-coercive like you can't
coerce people to change their religion,
all of that stuff. And so, when I hear
you because I've heard so many other
things. I think I know where you're
headed with that, but if you can define
like if I were to say, "Hey, Christians,
um go forth and prosper. Go go to the
far ends of the earth and bring Jesus to
people. Make people's lives better and
uh do it by writing. Do it by speaking.
Do it by having more children. Do it by
proselytizing." It sounds awesome. It
only starts sounding dark when you start
using words like, "It's propaganda. It's
this is a dangerous thing." It's like,
"Well, I would expect the religions of
the world to compete and to compete in
non-violent ways." Like I'm not going to
have beef with that. Like, "Yeah, that's
exactly what you should do." So, the
word dangerous makes sense if you're
just like, "I don't want my religion to
be the one that loses
even though I don't really have an
explanation as to why mine is better,
but that would make sense." Or if you
believe for some reason that they would
do all these non-violent jihads only to
lead to something violent. So, Walk me
through Yeah, yeah, yeah. They Okay,
they can do all the non-violent stuff
and a lot of them think it's great. Like
you say, Muslims don't see themselves as
the bad guys. Okay, so when they But you
said your parents wouldn't see them as
bad guys either. Yeah, not necessarily.
My parents I think would have had the
same idea with me, which is the
religion's messed up and the core
teachings, but we know a lot of nice
Muslims who don't do it.
Okay, that's the understanding in
general.
>> going to be the big thing that will
looming in this whole argument is why
why aren't we just talking about reform?
Why aren't we talking about Muslims
having a right to exist?
>> okay? Muslims need to talk about reform.
Is fair?
>> It's ridiculous for you and me to talk
about reform. If they want to reform it,
that's one thing and a lot of that's
been going on, but
we're talking a lot of good stuff, but
you did say something I want to unpack a
little bit, which is, you know, like
some of the verses in the Quran are good
and why are you looking at the bad ones?
So, I should tell you there's an entire
science of how Muslims approach that.
Because for Muslims, they want to Islam
is legalistic religion, okay? It's not I
would argue Christianity was very
legalistic in its own sense, but Islam
is legalistic in that it's not about,
you know, some spiritual, you know,
relationship I have. I mean, again,
Christianity didn't even have that idea
until a few centuries ago.
And in Islam, so it's a law. We're
looking for the law and we're deriving
it from the words of Allah and the
example of the prophet.
Now, you're right. I can open the Quran
and there's good verses and a lot of
that's
>> And good means peace Yeah, peaceful,
non-violent, cooperative,
and, you know, stuff that they a lot of
Muslim apologists will tell you, well,
it Look at that. So, what are you
talking about?
Now, the issue is the Muslim clerics who
have a huge role, in fact, they're part
of Sharia law. It's called Ijma, which
means consensus, which is if there's any
ambiguity, it's it's what the Islamic
clerics have agreed upon, that becomes
part of Sharia law, okay?
And
so, they approached it and they looked
and they said, yeah, there's a different
things. And then they realized, and I
you might have touched on this, but that
the the whole revelation, as it's
understood, of the Quran to Muhammad was
done based often times on the
circumstances of his life. And so, you
find that the earliest revelations they
they divide them by two. One is in
Mecca, that's the older one, later ones
in Medina. And they're I mean, they even
talk about them as the Medinan Quran and
the Meccan Quran, even though they're
one Quran. And so, the Meccan Quran is
where you have Muhammad was weak, he was
outnumbered, he didn't have any
followers for a while and then when he
did it was like 100. And you know, he's
living amongst what would be seen as a
hostile pagan peoples, the Quraysh of
Mecca.
Okay? Those are the verses where they
come off. There's no war, he's not
calling for jihad or anything like that.
He then he does the Hijra, he move the
migration in the year 622, goes to
Medina. And there he starts becoming a
political leader, okay? And before long,
he starts doing the jihad and he starts
going and
caravan raids and attacking and in eight
years, he's conquered almost most of
Arabia, including Mecca itself.
>> Was he like a military genius?
Uh I mean, these are He conquered a lot.
>> Yeah, but in the context of Arabia,
these would be seen as sort of small
scale. I mean, there's they're almost
described as, you know, Bedouin raids.
But he gets a good reputation, I assume.
>> No, no, he does and you can say, I mean,
yeah, I mean, some people would say, of
course, he had a military he was a mili-
a mili- a tactician to some degree,
right?
So, he wins and now, but inasmuch as he
gets stronger during this phase, the
Medina, and he keeps conquering, the
revelations now take a different tone.
Hm. Okay, so God starts revealing
different stuff.
>> Right. Now that you're able to Okay, now
you can go on the offensive. But before,
when you were weak, you yeah, you preach
peace. So, there's so now the clerics
have have concluded there's three
basically phases or or or
or there's three categories which any
Muslim, even today, can find themselves
in. One, you're completely outnumbered
by the infidel. Yeah. In which case,
yeah, you know, live and let live and
you should quote those Meccan verses.
Two, I'm sorry, in that phase, how much
is taqiyya?
Yeah, well, that's the other thing.
Taqiyya is another whole verse and it's
actually it's tied up with the doctrine
of having,
you know, not being loyal to infidels.
It's Quran 3:28.
And it basically says it's one of those
verses, do not befriend, you know, the
infidel. And that one that verse though
ends up by saying, unless it's by the
way of taking precautions. And that word
traces back to the word taqiyya. And
again, the clerics have um you know, uh
the exegesis of it is basically that,
yeah, okay, if [clears throat] you are
under non- infidel authority, you can
say whatever or pretend
whatever to make them not, you know,
persecute you. Right. Which means you
can
uh renounce Islam. You can convert to
Christianity if they're persecuting you,
let's say. You can engage in baptism.
That's what actually happened right
before um a lot and what drew on the
Inquisition actually in Spain because
there was a large Muslim population that
was engaged in that taqiyya. So, they're
pretending. Yeah, we're good Christians.
Yeah. But psych, just kidding, at home
we're teaching hatred of the infidel. In
one of my books, Sword and Scimitar, I
have a a long quote from a Spaniard who
said, "These people converted, they went
to church more than we did. They were
model Christians. They were always at
mass and re- It looked like they were
reading the Bible and it would go on
generation and generation. You'd think,
okay, three, four generations, yeah.
Then they find out at home they're
reading the Quran, preaching undying
hatred for the infidel and working to
subvert Spain back to Islam." And do you
have a mental model, like when you look
at the UK or the US, do you have a
mental model of like this is a very
small percentage of people that do this,
but because you can't tell if they're
actually moderate or if they're just
faking being moderate, that it creates a
real
>> have you have categories. You have the
open a valid jihadist, who I actually
find refreshing because they're honest.
telling you the truth.
>> Yeah. And this would be like the ISIS
type who literally send out tracts and
letters saying, "Here's why we're
fighting you. We're fighting you because
you're an infidel and we have to hate
you."
Okay, whereas other Muslims, smarter
ones maybe, will play the grievance
mantra. Oh, we're fighting you because
you started it, because of, you know,
whatever, colonialism, because you're
attacking the Arab world, whatever,
okay? And that's a lot of Islamist
groups engage in that. And that's the
jihad of the tongue, for example. Um but
you're right. So, then then you have
this gray zone who may be seen moderate
and maybe some are, but you don't know
which is the one who's pretending, which
is the one who's waiting for the
circumstances to change. Hm. Okay? I
give this analogy and and you know, you
were even saying, I think you mentioned
like in Europe and these growing Muslim
numbers, but you don't know. I mean,
it's a small number, it's a big number.
But here's the thing, if I'm a governor
or I'm a leader of, let's say, European
nation.
And my um
my duty to my people are first and
foremost.
I think all of them would agree with
this analogy
because everyone now agrees, even the
most conservative measure,
people will tell you you know, the
apologist for Islam who don't think it's
a big deal. They'll tell you, okay,
yeah, there's a bunch of rotten apples,
but maybe it's like 5% or maybe it's 1%
or maybe 10. You know, they'll minimize
it. But to me, that doesn't that that's
we still have a massive problem. It's
like saying, you know what? I'm going to
give you a jar of candy, there's 100
here.
Five are poisoned, no biggie. Okay,
let's let's eat them. Would you give
that to your kid? I wouldn't. Right.
Okay, because and again, I understand
the 90, 95, 99 are like that.
But why is it incumbent on me to take
this risk when I know it's part of that
and there are people doing this. We know
that. And this is what I mean, even even
the most liberal, leftist, woke person
will agree and say, yeah, I think most
Muslims are good, but yeah, I know
there's a few radicals. But
right there, you've just
you right there you've admitted to
something that I personally, if I was a
leader who cares about my people, I
wouldn't engage in that. I'm going to
ask just as I I can pre-empt what people
are thinking right now. So, every group
is going to have their crazies. Um I
don't know that McVeigh, who did the
Oklahoma City bombing, I don't know that
he quoted Christianity, but boy, I
wouldn't be surprised.
>> They say they are they try to claim
Okay. So, now it's like, well, do I
start being super paranoid about all
Christians or is it that well, hold on a
second, if you look at the Old
Testament, sure, there's some wacky shit
and I'm going to be stoning all kinds of
people. Uh but if you go, well, this is
New Testament Christianity, that's what
this is about, this is about following
in Jesus' footsteps and he clearly, if
you're modeling your behavior after him,
you have a lot harder time finding
somebody that goes on the offensive. Um
and however, on the Muslim side, if you
start really hardlining and going with
the word of the Quran, now you're
running into trouble. Is that where you
make the distinction or do you not and
you just go, hey, these have more
crazies than other places or their
crazies are more dangerous and that's
why my warning is about Muslims and not
about Christians. I also believe that
ideology will tap into dormant things
within side the human. And this is why
there's a book called Ordinary Men about
how Hitler turned these ordinary cops
into the most most ruthless killing
machine where they were out shooting
naked pregnant women during the
Holocaust. And so, it's like, yeah,
that's horrifying and that's doctrine
that comes and tells you, not only is
this okay, this is good and you should
do this and this is good for the German
people and yay. And so, I know that
humans will fall prey to doctrine that
makes them feel good about something
that from where I'm sitting is
absolutely psychotic. So, the reason I
look at Christians and I'm like, okay,
look, they are going to have their
crazies,
but if I can peel you off of the Old
Testament,
I've at least got more to work with over
here. It's far more poetic, it's far
more turn the other cheek, all that kind
kind stuff.
Uh I don't know the Quran well enough so
I can't tell you but looking at that
side
either you're saying this group for
whatever reason has a higher percentage
of what Tom Billy was calling crazy
people. I don't want to put that word on
you but either you believe that they
have a higher percentage of problematic
people or the doctrine somehow is more
problematic and therefore we need to be
worried about them and not the
Christians. Yeah, the latter. So I agree
with you that you have psychotic crazy
people of all races and and creeds,
okay?
But in Islam the teachings are prone to
exploits that sort of thing, okay? So
I'll give you an example.
Um
I remember I don't know I forgot who it
was some
Brennan maybe CIA agent CIA director a
few years ago
and he was trying to minimize the ISIS
phenomenon and he's saying you know this
has nothing to do with Islam.
ISIS Islamic State
and the atrocities they're engaging in
and he said because if you look at all
the people who are involved in it
they're all former criminals and they
just are criminals. And okay so and he's
trying to say oh these are just
criminals who are trying to justify
their criminality or could it be that
because Islam actually justifies this
stuff these criminal elements find
themselves gravitating towards it.
Okay? So beheading people and crucifying
them and engaging in raping and
enslaving okay there's people who think
and do that regardless of religion. Non
you know Westerners non Westerners all
races.
But if you have a religion that now
actually promotes this and puts a pious
veneer on it and tells you you're going
to go to heaven. I think that has you
know the capacity to really radicalize
and win over people as opposed to what
you're saying for example about Jesus.
Okay are there Christians who are
nominal Christians who want to engage in
violence and yeah of course. But they
don't have the ideological support the
way a Muslim or a convert to Islam would
have it and this again this is just Does
it actually say behead people Oh yeah
the Quran yeah yeah crucify them chop
their fingertips off
uh yeah yeah and slit their throat.
And so um so for example if you look in
Europe
>> [clears throat]
>> rape
in a lot of these countries it's it's
something like 80% by Muslim migrants.
Okay? Even though they're often under
10% of the population.
So what do you you know what what do you
make of that? There's there has to be a
correlation. They usually try not they
don't want these numbers to come out
they don't want people to understand
what's going on but it's like yeah
there's a correlate
if I okay a man who's again nominal
Christian
do some of them rape? Yeah obviously but
you're this person is not going to be
able to go quote the Bible, okay? And
the Old Testament thing is not really
the same we can talk about that it's not
the Old Testament is descriptive it's
not prescriptive. The Quran is
prescriptive. Uh give me the difference.
The difference is okay so a lot of
people tell you you know why are you
picking on the Quran the violence
didn't you read the Old Testament Joshua
genocide God okay. It's wild. Yeah.
The difference is this think of it
whatever you want, okay? But it's it's
no everyone who read it and understand
it it's written in a very temporal
[clears throat]
language it's and it's finite. It talks
about it gives you the names of the
enemies the Hivites the Perizzites the
Canaanites, okay? None of who exist. And
it uses a language which is basically
you understand
the the you the Hebrews in the now are
fighting this group of people. Now again
you can make of it whatever you want.
But it's not prescriptive in the sense
that in the Quran it's the same thing
you know there were actual historic
enemies that the Arabs were fighting in
the 7th century the Byzantines the
Eastern Roman Empire the Sassanians the
the Quraysh the you know the pagans but
they're not given their name they're
actually called the non Muslims the
kafir, okay? Which is the infidel
translated. What you're describing
sounds to me less like that it the Old
Testament isn't prescriptive it's more
that the Old Testament is specific and
the Quran is generalized.
>> It's open-ended even the the verbs. So
when you read the verb of killing the
infidel
it's in the present you know fight and
kill the infidel. So if I'm a Muslim I
read it okay it's you know it's speaking
to me in the now whereas I read an Old
Testament passage about Joshua warring
okay it is what it is it doesn't
necessarily I don't read it as this is
instruction for me.
Okay
um
how do you feel about the following
statement? If
let's to me as I hear this I have not
read the Old Testament nor have I read
the Quran so people that know more than
me can
think something totally different but
Old Testament at the headline level I've
heard enough that I'm like this is wild
shit and I'm just going to set it all
aside cuz it's so crazy it makes me
dislike their version of God that is not
interesting to me at all. The behavior
that seems condoned even if it's not
told you need to go do this
is crazy and I've certainly heard stuff
like you can stone people to death for
homosexuality and things like that which
Leviticus yeah. Yeah I couldn't sign
against harder if I tried. So it's like
okay all of that is atrocious and so I
look at that stuff and I'm hand wavy
away to like you obviously need to get
away from that. And so I feel like it
would be just to do the same thing to
the Quran. So is it that accidentally
the way that the Old Testament is
structured linguistically it just
doesn't have the mind virus effect into
the present that the Quran accidentally
ends up having so it's not that uh we
should ascribe to
uh Muhammad any extra like sort of bad
vibes or you know whatever you want to
say than you would to the writers of the
Old Testament it's just that his
linguistic choices end up having this
knock-on effect throughout history that
were not present in the Old Testament or
does that feel naive? No no that's that
sounds like a secular rationalization,
okay? But a believer of a Christian or a
Muslim the Christian and and I assume
you know possibly the Jew could say no
this it was intentionally written that
way um so we don't go and kill people
today whereas the Muslim will tell you
no it's intentionally written that way
because jihad is still alive in the now.
That's the knock-on effect I'm talking
about. It gives people as they interpret
it uh the lens through which to say that
interpretation. Ultimately it it does
come down to
uh the things happening in the books are
pretty horrifying. Yeah yeah I I I
I mean there's there's people who've
said if you really compare the violence
and the atrocities and the sort of bad
vibes in the Old Testament that they're
worse than the Quran, okay?
>> [snorts]
>> But again it really goes it goes to I'm
not looking at
I'm not looking at yeah the words are
the words but how do they guide people
today? And you we're not seeing Jews and
Christians doing that sort of thing,
okay?
We are seeing Muslims doing that sort of
thing. I've given some reasons why I
think that's the case because it's seen
it's described the language is very
including the tense it's prescriptive
it's generic it's open-ended. When it
says fight okay so like I told you the
Old Testament says fight these groups of
people who don't exist. The Quran says
fight the non Muslim until he is
subjugated. Well if I'm a Muslim and I
read that there's non Muslims all around
me and they're not subjugated. So that's
why I think it takes more of an
immediate tone. Okay.
Okay so we're knee deep in the doctrine
here.
>> And otherwise you know just to continue
this like so otherwise how would one
explain it? Why is it that this is
happening amongst Muslims? It's obvious
and it's not happening if all religions
have their wackos why is it so
overwhelmingly you look at any of these
European countries and you look at
[snorts] you know the number of
terrorist attacks and they're
overwhelmingly Muslims even though
Muslims are minority. Yeah. What if if
it's not what I'm saying what else could
it be? I think I have a different read
on all of this than you. I'll lay it out
here so people don't think I'm dodging
the question but this is probably not
yet the point in the interview where we
go down this path but it my thing goes
like this.
Culture clashes are real I worry about
that a lot they decohere a society and
then you get all kinds of madness.
Um
I'm a big believer that cultures are
going to compete. I want my culture to
win because I grew up in it and it
treated me very well and I love it I
love the way it made me feel I love the
way it makes me feel towards other
people makes me feel open and inclusive
I love all of that but it also makes me
want to play to win and so there's this
really cool thing if I want an open
playing field and yet I want to get so
good that I can beat everybody else. Um
so that's why I love my culture and why
I want to see it win but I also only
want an even playing field and so that's
where this gets strange where it's like
okay how protective do we be? Now I'm a
person who believes you have to have
very strict immigration policies so I
have a feeling we'll agree on that but
it might be for different reasons so
that's the part that I will hopefully
we'll have time at the end to get to.
Um so what I'm trying to tease out is
is um
are Muslims right now culturally cuz
I've heard you you've been very clear on
doctrine and your hypothesis is it
creates this way outsized and very
unique impact on the world to me it's
very in line with what Sam Harris says I
think there's a lot there it it makes
sense as an argument. Um and what I'm
trying to figure out is is it that or is
it just that they're having more kids
they're more confident in themselves and
so they're not afraid to be like yeah
fuck you my religion is better and so
yes I'm going to come to your country
you're wealthy you guys have cooler shit
I'm going to come here I'm going to
raise my kids here but we're going to uh
terraform this place culturally. We're
going to take it over we're going to
take the advantages that you guys have
keep that rolling but at the same time,
you guys are living a super lame,
um,
like value system life, and we're going
to take that over. And it's like, yeah,
I both understand why a culture would
think that's a good idea if they have
like the confidence of their culture,
and I understand why the country that
that's being done to would be like,
"Fuck right off." And so, when I see
Japan being like, "Nope, you guys got to
go." I find it funny. Now, I also I
tried to do business in Japan.
It did It went nowhere. Like it was So,
they're not open, in other They're not
open in the slightest, and it's created
this incredibly unique culture that I
have I have gained so much, um,
enjoyment from, insights from, whatever,
that I completely respect
and enjoy being able to interact with
their culture. I don't think it's better
than ours, but I really find it
engaging. So, the fact that they would
tell me like, "Hey, we want to do
business with Japanese people. You can
go away." Bugger off. Like, I'm like,
"Hey, I get it. No worries. Like, you do
you. It's part of what makes you
interesting." So, now, I get it. It
becomes very existential from
a cultural perspective. So, I'm watching
what's happening in Europe, and I am
aghast that they don't believe in
themselves, and they look at what
they've accomplished. They had the
largest empire in the world, and all
they can see is, "But we were bad
people." Like, and I'm just like, "What
the fuck?" So, anyway, that to me feels
like a very inappropriate read of what
you've done historically. I'm all for
people going, "Well, there were parts of
this that were horrific, and so we'd
never rerun that experiment, but at the
same time to be able to see what it
looks like when we're muscular and
strong and we believe in ourselves and
like all of that, we're going to check
ourselves so that we don't, you know,
sort of redo, and I mean, I think in
many ways the American system post-World
War II was us trying to do colonialism
right. We'd go in and help, but we
wouldn't take over. We had a military
base, but we're not trying to tell you
what to do. So, it's like, we want to
control the economy, but like, you can
still be Japanese. You know what I mean?
So, that we got closer. You trust me.
You can go down very dark paths with
things the US has done, and you
hopefully get better and better and
better over time, but nevertheless, I do
not share the, sort of, self-suicidal,
self-flagellating look at America or the
UK or wherever, but I also don't
immediately extend to, um, Islam that
right now is like having their moment.
Like, they're it's working, man. Having
babies, believing in your book, like
recruiting the shit out of other people,
telling them like, "Yo, these guys are
weak. Like, look at these idiots the way
they run their country. Like, forget all
that. Like, we're going to be tough.
We're going to be strong. We're not
going to be pushed around."
Hey, now, to your point at the
beginning, there comes a time where,
wait, hold on. If you're going to tell
me how to live, now I have a real
fucking problem. And so, part of the
reason I wanted to interview you is I am
looking at this going, "Hmm, [snorts]
is there a uniquely escalatory problem
where this religion, the diehards,
you've been very clear, and it makes a
lot of sense to me that it's probably a
small number, but that the diehards are
going to make problems for me, and
especially because I believe that
American culture right now does not
believe in itself, is very weak, but I
want to see it reassert itself. I want
to see America be strong again from a
cultural perspective. I'm not Christian,
even a little bit. However, I believe I
have grown up in the cultural soup of
believing that the individual is
sovereign, that there is a little bit of
divinity in all of us, and therefore,
there should be individual freedoms and
all of that. I look at Islam, does not
seem compatible with that. Maybe people
will make me a believer. I doubt it, but
it's certainly possible. So,
that's sort of how I come at all of
this, and as I was saying before we
started rolling, what I want to
understand are all the base assumptions
that you have that lead you to your
conclusions, because then I can go
either agree with the base assumptions
or I don't, and then I can build my own
thinking rather than just being a parrot
who's like, "Oh, I've never thought
through this, so I'm just going to
parrot back what you say or what
somebody else says." No, no, no. I
understand the base assumptions, and so
now I'm like, "Well, is that true or
not?" Okay. So, we were on doctrine.
Have you laid out all of the doctrines
you believe that make Islam uniquely
problematic, or are there Yeah, there
were three. So, the first one I
mentioned, the loyalty enmity, tribalism
essentially, but deified, which creates
the hostility. That manifests itself as
the jihad, so that's the physical
manifestation that we're familiar with,
which can be expressed as terrorism,
warfare, conquest.
>> [gasps]
>> And the third one is basically the idea
that once a conquest happens, which kind
of goes to where you're going,
you know, so let the I think you're
asking me like, "Okay, Muslims are just
competing like everyone else, and
they're having their moment, but is it
going Is it going to get dark in the
end?" So, what happens to conquered, you
know, subject populations historically
is not what, for example, happened under
the Mongols. Okay? So, the Mongols
actually when they would and they were
really brutal, and
exactly. There's no one No one has
reached that level, okay? But they
actually gave freedom of religion. And
we weren't supremacist against you
because you believe this or that or the
other thing.
Islam doesn't have that, okay? So, in
Islam, once you're conquered,
you know, you pay tribute, and you have
to be a second-class citizen. Now, this
actually continues throughout the
Islamic world. If you talk about Egypt,
my ancestral homeland, that's what you
will see more, not necessarily physical
persecution. That happens, okay? But
what's ingrained in the culture is a
sort of discriminatory attitude towards
the non-Muslim, let's say the Christian.
You are a second-class citizen. Okay.
So, why weren't your parents more angry
with Muslims? I'll tell you why, because
they're born into that, and that's
normal. And, you know, there's a word
for it, the mimetude, which means, you
know, a mim is like that kind of person.
>> Right. They're called mims, and mimetude
is this mental, you know, mentality
you're born into it, and you just accept
it. Yeah, I mean, they're the overlords.
They're the majority, so I I need to
know my place. So, and not necessarily
my parents that that were like that, but
that's kind of what influences a lot of
people like that. They're just that
They're born into it. That's how I have
to be. It's a fair price. They're the
majority. The idea of, "Oh, everyone has
their free, you know, freedom of like
the American or Western idea." That's so
alien, and I would say it's not organic.
I mean, we have to learn that. It's like
a caste system.
>> Yeah, yeah, and that's more organic. So,
it's organic to be, "I'm a minority. Let
me just be grateful they're not killing
me." You know, "They're giving me some
measure of tolerance, that's good."
That's I think what how most people
would understand it. And what we have is
actually
you know, it's it's it's manufactured.
It's good, but it's not it's not
naturally an organic thing that just
everyone realizes, "Oh, yeah, everyone's
equal." That's what I mean. It goes back
to the tribalism. And is it in the Quran
that you have to be a second-class
citizen? Yeah, in your Quran 9:29, it
says, "Fight fight the people of the
book," which is understood as Jews and
Christians, who actually So, this is
actually good. I mean, the other people
who are not Jews and Christians, you're
supposed to just kill them unless they
convert. The Jews and the Christians,
according to this verse, 9:29, you fight
them until you until they keep fighting
you, kill them, or they submit, and they
pay tribute, and it says, "And they live
feeling subjugated and humbled."
And then there's a whole entire
jurisprudence about how to make them
feel that way. So, historically, there
were times when the Jew or Christian
comes in pays,
um, the tax gatherer has to pull their
beard and slap them. They have to crawl
on all fours. Uh, that's in the Quran?
>> No, no, no. That's That was a practice
based on the verse.
>> Based on the verse that they have to
feel humbled, which is in the Quran.
>> Uh-huh. The jurists would would, um,
enforce these types of humiliation
rituals
because of that. Right. Yeah.
Okay. So, anyway, so those are the
doctrines,
but to your point, okay, you were I
think, uh, and, you know, correct me if
I'm if I'm not if I'm paraphrasing you
wrong, but you were saying kind of it's
it's okay
if [snorts] Muslims want to come in, and
it's you know, they're competing with
ideas, and they're proud of their way,
and, you know, they're just bringing
their thing,
right? Which was okay, I think you're
saying.
But the problem is what? What was If If
you're going to force your religion on
other people, now I have beef.
>> Okay. All right.
So, it's not an either/or with Islam,
okay? It's not either they are just, you
know, this is their moment,
or they are, you know, just,
they have a dark agenda, okay? The two
can work together, actually, and they
often do. And I'll give you a perfect
historical precedent, which may
illuminate what we're discussing,
because you were talking about, you
know, like the self-flagellation of the
West and whatnot.
So, historically, if you go back to the
colonial era, and, again, the problem
with the colonial era is most people
don't know what happened before it,
okay? Which was the long-drawn jihad and
conquest of Christian territories.
And the colonial era was finally when
Europe was now stronger and and went on
the offense, and it entered the Muslim
lands, which were formerly Christian,
okay? Now, um,
what they did is, okay, you can say they
conquered the Arabs and the Muslim and
the you know, Asians and Africans and
whatnot in during the colonial era. But
the difference is they actually brought
a lot of good stuff. Honestly. Okay,
they actually brought science,
technology, medicine, progress, which
was not there, literacy, okay? Printing
presses. That's what the Europeans
brought during the colonial era. All
right. Pause right there for a second. I
think this is going to be very
important. So, obviously, there are
people right now in the comments
freaking out that you would say that
anything positive came out of
colonialism. So, now let's set the
stage. Why didn't they have those things
before? Why did Who? The Arabs, Muslims?
Uh, whoever whatever nation they're
going into that should be, and I'm sure
some of them do actually say, "Well, we
did get a couple bits and bobs out of
this." Um but why didn't they have those
things? Was there something about the
West, the culture, the religion,
whatever? Like does Christianity bring
you science? Because Christians killed a
lot of scientists. So like what what was
it about the West that was good? What's
the relationship between um
Islam and the Dark Ages? Like I know
there was a tie there. So
walk me through why there's even that
dichotomy in the first place where
you could get the West coming in and
colonialism despite the brutality is
somehow also a little bit positive.
All right. And to try to answer that,
let me tell you what what what let's say
Islam did. So we have we can kind of
balance what we're talking about. So I
told you before that is the conquest and
Muslims enter Christian even European
territories and they conquer them. Until
today, okay, if you look at Spain and
the Balkans and and they and they have
their deep history the Spaniards and the
Balkans and they still have areas that
have been so devastated just from
warfare, okay, from with the Muslims.
And what was brought at the time? I
mean, literally, if you look at the
sources, it was in mass enslavement,
okay? And we're talking about from the
very beginning when I
let's say the 8th century when Muslims
entered Spain
until uh you know, the Ottomans are
finally become the you know, the the the
old man of Europe, which is like in the
19th century, okay? You'll you look at
that there's million there's all this
enslavement, but there's not none of the
countries in the European countries and
they all tell you can go talk to
Hungarians, go talk to Romanians, they
tell you our land has been devastated
and there was nothing brought here,
okay? And and not necessarily even
because
uh you know, I mean, yeah, it was
because the Muslims are not going to
give the good stuff to their subject
slave people, all right? But they didn't
also have the technology at the time. So
now you're asking me why did the West
end up having the great technology?
That's you know, that's open to debate
why they progressed. But they had it and
they brought it. So it was actually
called it was understood and and by
Europeans as a you're maybe you're
familiar the white man's burden.
I've certainly heard the phrase. Rudyard
Kipling okay, Rudyard Kipling he was a
well, he was a writer and some clerk I
think in India. This is during the
colonial era. And you know, the white
man and I
talk about triggering, but the white man
saw his his his mission is to go and
civilize the savages of Asia, the Muslim
countries, Africa, okay? So they went,
they conquered, they colonized, but they
saw it like look, we're bringing them to
this, that, and the other thing. Now
here's [snorts] the important point.
Okay, that's the a lot of people say,
"Well, that's the European narrative."
You guess what? If I and I've read books
and I've because I've researched this,
if you look at let's say the 1800s,
which is the high high moment of
colonialism depending on the country,
also in the early 1900s
if you look at the writings of the
people living there in Egypt, which I
have, they talk about this as the best
time ever. Okay? Colonialism?
>> Yes. Colonialism. Algeria just passed a
law because Algeria is written by people
that were I'm writing this sentence
under colonialism? Yeah, this is the era
they're living in and the way they talk
and the way they describe things, this
is the best time ever. Are they not
worried that their writing is being
monitored?
No, because everyone agreed with them.
Okay, Ataturk so the Ottoman Empire was
the scourge of Europe for centuries.
This is a historic fact. It was the
Jihadist standard-bearer more than the
Arabs historically.
Once they start losing
and Europe is now becoming stronger So
they're losing to Europe. Yeah, losing
to Europe, losing land, you know, just
using losing the momentum and now Europe
is stronger and moving in.
Once that starts happening, you know
what they do? They completely emulate
the Europeans. They get rid
Turkish used to be Ottoman Turkish was
written with the Arabic script. They
said, "Oh, that's backwards. We want to
adopt the European alphabet." We shave
they all shave their beards. They put on
suits and ties. Women were dressed in
western dress. No more hijab, okay?
That's not because Europeans forced
them. This was because you were talking
about confidence. It was because the
European colonialists were very
confident about their culture. The
subject people saw the boons they were
coming with and they were the winning
dog and guess what? We want to be like
that. We want to copy that. You if you
look at pictures from these Middle
Eastern nations, you will be amazed. If
you look at an 1920s picture compared to
2020, you 1920s you'll think you're
looking at Europe. And in 2020 you're
looking at you know, 7th century Arabia
is how it looks. A lot of that was
because there was a sort of symbiotic
relationship between and which is still
going on today and you have alluded to
it, but it's much worse today. It's the
opposite. Back then it was a confident
Europe who is coming in
and Muslims are now
you know, Islam fell to the wayside and
there's a theory that the and I kind of
touched on it. The reason that Islam
ever even mattered was because it was
seen as the winning horse.
People cited Muhammad once he started
getting stronger and the more the
conquest spread, the more people became
Muslims and oh, you become richer and
you have a piece of the plunder and etc.
etc. Okay? So when Muslims started
saying, "Oh, you know what? Islam gets
me nothing. I'm living in the desert,
whereas these people are progressing and
they're bringing all this magic with
them, science and technology and
medicine. Oh, well, let's act like them,
okay?" That's literally what happened.
And I was just telling you there's an
Algeria just passed a law because
actually if you're an Algerian and it's
mostly this is
geared towards older Algerians who lived
during the colonial era of under France,
if you speak well of it, you can go to
jail.
Okay? If you speak well of the French
colonial era. And I was telling you
because a lot of people look back
nostalgically
older generations, that was the good
time, okay? Now
what's happening today, which you've
touched on, is the exact opposite.
Inasmuch as the West has started to lose
faith in itself, lose its confidence and
become you know, like a doormat and tell
everyone, "Oh, your culture's way better
than ours." That Muslims are not
impressed by that. That doesn't inspire
them. That doesn't make them like you.
That actually gives them nothing but
contempt and and they say, "Yeah, okay.
Yeah, you're right. My culture is better
than yours."
And so and this all really coalesced
with one man.
His name is Sayyid Qutb. He was an
Egyptian. He's with the Muslim
Brotherhood and you know, by all by all
measures he was moderate if you want to
use that term. And then he came to the
United States in the '50s
and he spent time and he was just aghast
at what he saw, what he considered
immoral behavior, especially that men
and women were freely consorting. Long
story short, he went back and he became
a very popular writer and chief
theoretician for the Brotherhood.
And his conclusion was, "Okay, yeah,
these people are good with science,
technology, whatever. Let's appropriate
and learn that, but we want nothing to
do with their culture because it's just
pathetic and it's just they're they're
pathetic. This is they're just crazy."
So what what what culture is a Muslim
going to fall back on then? Well, Islam.
So there's definitely been that kind of
response, but it's it's incomplete. It's
the
you know,
you're telling me about your viewers and
this really reminds me of uh
I I had a I did an interview with me and
Peter Boghossian. Which is fantastic.
>> Yeah, and a cameraman I think if you've
seen it
>> I have. was unhinged. Yeah. And
everything he said I mean, I'm just
sorry, but it's like you're wrong. You
don't know your history. It just seems
like people today the history they've
been indoctrinated in in is
white man bad, everyone good. White man
evil, everyone passive victim. And I'm
not here to exonerate white man. I don't
think of myself as a white man, by the
way, okay? So but whatever the white man
did, you know what? The other guy did
it, too. And in it often in a much more
graphic way.
And it's kind of like so where's the
balance? And
you know, I even told him everything was
like, "Oh, well, colonialism did this."
Well, I'm like, "What about the thousand
years of Jihad and conquest and
colonization? That doesn't matter?
You're talking about the one century
where actually Muslims liked it because
they got so many benefits? That's the
nightmare?" So my point is there's a lot
of people who've been really misled with
history. You know, a lot of people we
know of the concept of fake news, which
I think is very dangerous because uh
but as I always say, fake news is
ephemeral. It creates its mischief and
then dissipates. I find fake history
much more problematic and very dangerous
because it creates overarching
narratives and paradigms and people see
reality through it. And if it's fake,
your everything's going to be just
completely distorted in your mind. What
are the beats of fake history that are
relevant to this conversation? Well,
I'll give you an I'll give you a very
popular one, which is uh if I speak
about slavery, that means white people
enslaving blacks.
Is that real? Yeah, that happened, of
course. Is it bad? Yes. But if you if
you just think it's that's it, that's
all that ever happened, well, then white
people are evil.
And people say that. I saw this uh she's
a professor, Bridget Cooper at Rutgers
University, black woman. She literally
says that, you know, like and the way
she talks is as if nobody's enslaved
anyone except white people. Okay, so
that is a fake history. If you now
understand that yeah, whites did that
but blacks enslaved whites, blacks
enslaved blacks, whites enslaved whites,
okay? And it's been a non-stop thing
that has happened historic. Muslims
enslaved everyone, okay?
And if anything, well, guess what? Who
did abolish slavery? It was whites. At
least they did that, okay? Around the
world. So if you So my point you see,
but if you if you jettison all that out
and oh, it's only the white man who did
slavery, that's going to poison your
mind and then you will believe in the
woke theories kind of like, "Oh, yeah,
because you know, everyone's problem
every black person's problem in America
is because of people are still racist,
you know?" You're going to believe that
because if you believe in that fake
history. But if you understand it in
context, which is everyone did it, but
at least we can say one group abolished
it. So, it kind of changes how you may
see the actual reality that's unfolding
before us.
And what is what is some of the framing
that people would have about Muslims or
Islam itself that are misleading, that
are giving them a different picture of
what's happening right now versus what
you believe is actually happening right?
Right. Like so so for example, the fake
histories about Islam. Um those are so
deep. One I'll give you one I always
quote this cuz it's very I mean it's
been etched in my head.
Um there's a a former professor um he
wasn't mine, but I used to see him at
Georgetown University. I used to attend
there in the Middle Eastern programs and
his name is John Esposito and in the
early 2000s he was like the dawn. I mean
he was the editor of the Oxford history
of Islam and the FBI and CIA and all the
intelligence agencies would talk to him
about terrorism.
And he has a line in one of his books
>> [clears throat]
>> the book is called Islam the straight
path. And the line goes as follows, five
centuries of peaceful coexistence
elapsed between Christians and Muslims
until an imperial power play led to a
series of holy wars which have left
centuries of enduring mistrust. Which
means
from the dawn of Islam until the first
crusade in 1095, peaceful coexistence
until the first crusade and now Muslims
are upset. Okay. As I've alluded, those
four or five centuries actually is when
Muslims savagely conquered three
quarters of the Christian world. All
right? In one year alone in 1009, okay?
This is the same the same century of the
first crusade later, one caliph
according to Muslim sources destroyed
30,000 churches. Yo. Yeah. Okay? So,
imagine this kind of fake history where
you're telling people, "Oh, Muslims were
great from the beginning and they were
so nice to Christians until those evil
Crusaders decided to do that." That's a
a primary example a premier example of
fake history and if I believe that, well
of course I'm going to believe Muslims
are still being abused by those stupid
white Christian colonialist people etc.
etc. But if I understand the truth,
actually it was Muslims who were
the it's it's it's it's known the first
crusade is a belated rebuttal to
centuries of Islamic conquest. And in
fact in the century in the decades
before the first crusade, the atrocities
had reached a new high, okay? Of attacks
on Christians and pilgrims and
destroying churches. So, you're saying
that the Crusades, at least the first
one, was a direct response to aggression
on behalf of Muslims. That's what the
that's what the sources make very clear.
And what this was just part of the we
have to wage jihad and so we're going to
go out.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was it was always
bad of course under
Christians had always been going to the
holy land even after the Islamic
conquest. And depending on who was the
leader, you know, at least they would
expect extra money and taxes. But if
there were radicals or whatever, there'd
always be uprisings and even when
pilgrims would get there, they'd get
killed, raped. A lot of Why were they
going just to see the holy land and pay
tribute? Like find the rock that Jesus
came out from behind Pilgrimage was a
huge thing in Europe.
>> weren't trying to take it over.
>> No. No. No. Just pilgrimage to go
worship at you know, the holy sites.
>> Okay. And so they basically now every
time they go, there's some sort of ultra
violent aggro and The Turks the Seljuk
Turks specifically had risen right
around this time and they were engaged
in all sorts of just I mean horrible I
describe it in one of my chapters in
Sword and Scimitar where they
I mean in one city they burned a
thousand it was known as a church of a
thousand it was a city of a thousand one
churches they burned them all to the
ground. It was an Armenian city. They
would pull out the entrails of people. I
mean
rape women on the altars including nuns.
All right? So, that sort of thing.
That's but
how many people know this if you hear
the first crusade? No, the first crusade
was a colonial racist venture. No, it
was actually trying to redress all these
wrongs and put an end to them. Okay? So,
this is what I mean. This it's this
context is important and if you don't
have that, you have fake history which
will feed into all of these ideas which
is oh white man bad, Muslim innocent.
But if you have at least some balance,
you have the truth. Okay. Well, at least
I mean it it could still be whatever it
is today, but at least you have
a solid accurate foundation to
understand it through. Okay. So, through
all that history and you've mentioned
Spain a little bit, but it's probably
worth walking us through that timeline.
I think you said it went on for like
seven or eight hundred years. Um walk us
through that timeline. I want people to
understand the pattern that you see
emerging as you look at this cuz I think
it will speak directly to what you see
now and how people should interpret
that. So,
as we take
Muslim behavior over, you know, hundreds
of years, a thousand years, I think you
document up to 1400 years in certainly
in Sword and Scimitar um
what pattern emerges?
>> The Spanish example is a good one
because it's really a microcosm of
everything we're talking about. You can
see that Spain was almost like um
you know, Europe, but it was a perfect
little it's a peninsula. It's not
little.
Islam invades in the year 711 is the
year given
and [snorts] essentially conquers it
except for a very small group of rebels
who get holed up in these Asturian
mountains in the northwestern quadrant
of the peninsula.
And the Muslim sources say like, "Yeah,
whatever. They're like 10 people living
on living in a rock. Who cares?"
Slowly these and
the other rest of the Christians and
there were Jews there as well had become
subjugated by the Muslims at this point.
Okay? So, now they're they're paying the
tribute the dhimmi's exactly.
Slowly and slowly decade after decade,
century after century, the Christians in
the north starts coming down and this is
the Reconquista.
The main traditional you know, And this
literally takes hundreds of years. Well,
okay. So, the conquest is 711
and it doesn't end until 1492.
Whoa.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. So,
this is this is how it starts. And you
can look at the map and you know, the
Christians slowly slowly keep coming and
then there's vicissitudes. Muslims win
more land and Christians win more land
and it keeps going on and on. It's by
and large it's almost over by the mid
like 1250s, but you have Granada
in the very southern tip and that's
still a Muslim kingdom until 1492. Um
and you know, okay. So, when you look at
that, it's funny to me because again
here we go here we go with the fake
histories. A lot of historians have
tried to say, "Oh, we actually this was
a great time of
of cooperation and you know, you had
Muslims, Jews and Christians living in
peace and in harmony."
And here's the thing, okay? We just said
this is centuries. If you look at it,
they're basically talking about maybe a
decade in those centuries where all it
was is grand architecture and and
and but in that context
more progressive scientifically than the
rest of the archaic Europe. Okay? But it
even in that you find inconvenient
hiccups. So, there's for example
something called the Martyrs of Cordoba.
And this is around I want to say 850.
This would fall within the timeline of
the golden age that supposedly you know,
the Christians and Jews and Muslims
have.
But the Martyrs of Cordoba were
basically Christians who had been
dhimmi's
and they had reached the point where
they just got tired of even though
they're paying their tribute and they
can be Christians of being pressured
because that was always an ongoing
thing. It's an ongoing thing today, you
know, where you're you're mocked for
being a Christian for example.
>> [snorts]
>> Um and just
they got tired of it that they started
just speaking up real loud and
blaspheming essentially by saying your
prophet is is is is a false prophet
Muhammad. There's only one God, Jesus
Christ etc. And they were all something
they're known as the Martyrs of Cordoba.
There's something like 50. They were all
beheaded, boiled in oil, crucified,
skinned alive including women. Okay? So,
that's the golden age. All right? I just
to give you an idea. Um outside of that
was just pure carnage non-stop
Christians, Muslims fighting back. In
the Christian mentality where it's
Reconquista, it's we're reconquering our
land cuz Muslims did conquer. It was a
Christian territory when the Muslims
invaded.
Um
and that goes on and on and on and then
you have the the pivotal moment which I
think I touched on is about taqiyya. So,
this is actually a perfect example of
the taqiyya.
Now you have Spain the the Christians
have conquered all of Spain or the
Iberian peninsula. This of course
includes Portugal and a Portuguese
people get upset when I just keep saying
Spain. So, you know, Spain and Portugal.
And
now you have Islam is confined to
Granada. It's something like half a
million people.
Initially, the Spaniards okay, they they
after they conquered them in 1492, they
said you can stay Muslim, you can
practice sharia, do your This is the
part people don't hear.
And what happened is all of a sudden a
lot of those Muslims were trying to
subvert Spain back. They were helping
the Barbary Muslim pirates raid. They
were trying to ally with the Ottoman
Turks, fellow Muslims again.
>> [snorts]
>> And before long
the Christians just finally understood,
"Okay, your religion is inherently not
going to is incompatible."
So, they said, "Sorry. You have two
choices now. You either become a
Christian or you leave. Go back to North
Africa whence they had come in the 8th
century.
And now and now here's now
the the common day rendering is this.
First of all, no one's going to tell you
that they were given freedom originally
and that they were trying to subvert
Spain back to Islam. And they're going
to tell you just randomly Christians
because they're crazy evil bigoted
Catholics decided to they can't live in
peace and they said, "Muslims, you have
to become Christians." Okay? No, it was
done because in the context of the times
it it understood that the first of all,
there's no atheism in this period. You
you're you're going to be one religion
or another. And if you're a Muslim and
we already know they at this point
they've translated, they understand the
Quran, they're saying what I am saying
about these doctrines.
And so, okay, either you become like us
in which case we assume you're going to
stop hating and trying to kill us. Okay,
at least your the further you know, your
second generations and third or you
leave.
So, all of a sudden they all converted.
Half a million, okay? And then later on
we find out that they found they got
fatwas, okay? Fatwas an Islamic decree
from a a jurist
a high-ranked scholar.
And several of them and they said, "Now
you can do taqiyya." And taqiyya is,
okay, you can convert, you can become
Christians, you can have the Eucharist,
you can go to mass, you can do the whole
nine yards, but as long as in your heart
you're still a Muslim and you're still
trying to help Islam, okay? It's fine.
And they all converted. Okay?
And now why I find it amusing because if
you look at the records as I have and I
talk about a little bit in
in sword and scimitar
the Christians just couldn't believe it.
And there's one who's who's like, "These
people it was for generations they acted
like model Christians, better than us,
the native Spaniards and Portuguese."
And then we found they would go to
church and all that and then we'd find
they were at homes and as I told you
preaching jihad and teaching their
children how they have to hate and etc.
And that's what gave rise to the
Inquisition, at least in Spain, because
you had all this huge mass and a lot of
the Muslims were saying, "No, no, I'm a
good Christian." And some were and some
were being busted for you know, being
doing taqiyya. That's what led to the
Inquisition. I'm not necessarily
justifying it. I'm just giving you an
idea because the the ponty python kind
of
version which unfortunately too many
people believe is, oh no, they're just
crazy evil
Christians and Catholics and they just
don't believe in tolerance freedom and
they decided we're going to torture
everyone until they become Christian.
No, as you can see there's a deeper
context, there's a deeper story to it.
And then in the end the Spaniard just
said, "You know what? There we can't
figure it out. This is too hard.
Everyone has to go." And so they were
all expelled. And now the irony is you
find out today Spain just brought like a
million migrants from Africa who just
walked in and they just gave them free
citizenship. Okay? And so so you know,
it's interesting because and a lot of
those migrants
you find that they engage in the same
sorts of behavior. They have that at
least that tribalistic. They don't have
to be sophisticated in theologically
understood or learned in Islam, but that
old tribalism is just there. It's human.
Okay? And they go there and they pray on
whatever and they destroy and they
exploit the Somalis, you know, here in
Minnesota that mentality, okay? So, you
know, someone so the continuum continues
with Islam, but the West has had a
massive break and it just doesn't learn
from its history and it's just repeating
it and going out of its way, which is
why all these countries which is why the
West today, Europe is so much more
powerful than Islam
military, technologically, economically.
I mean, you could it could destroy it.
If if the West was governed by Genghis
Khan he could destroy Islam, right?
Yeah. I would say given
given what he's known for.
>> And yet at no time in any and
and Europe for the longest time before
the colonial era was the weak horse.
Islam was the behemoth surrounding it,
okay? That's how it was understood. So,
it's ironic that those Europeans fought
tooth and nail to preserve their way of
life. And today you have this sort of
decadent West which is all powerful and
it's just it's it's doing everything to
kill itself and bring in people who
don't share its values, don't share its
worldview, are not assimilating, openly
so.
And
so so
I guess that's the long version to
answer your you know, what's the
warning. Okay, so we have this pattern
that we see repeating through history.
Uh we just had Spain let in. They
originally claimed just 500,000 That's
like 1.3 million or something.
>> [clears throat]
>> wild wild number. Yeah. Um okay, so
>> guy says so we can he I don't I forget
the you know, the phraseology, but he
was basically saying so you guys can
become citizens and outvote the right.
Yeah.
>> Like something to the effect that I want
you guys to get the voting so you can
vote for us and we can keep doing this
and shut down the right. Yeah. Yeah,
you'll you'll get to one of my can of
worms, so we'll set that aside for a
second. Um
what's going to be the consequence of
this? How does this play out across
Europe? I'm watching what's happening in
UK which because my wife is British, I'm
very very close to that problem.
Obviously what Spain is doing is pretty
wild. You look at Brussels and it's
crazy. Uh and a lot of people will say,
"Ah, it's not really that big of a
number. I'm not sure what people are
talking about." Um but as you sort of
run the scenario to
bring up Peter Boghossian again he he is
saying that um
he believes that Europe is already dead.
That [snorts] from a demographic
position it the certainty of their
demise just from a what part of the
population they make up in their own
country is so already done that he with
a straight face
believes that they should negotiate
basically a surrender. I and I don't
think I'm misrepresenting his position
at all.
>> said that to me numerous times. Yeah, so
because he's saying like we'll get
abused down the road as they take over
the country, so we might as well
negotiate it now so we can basically
limit the abuse that we'll face in the
future. It's pretty wild. Like
>> I always hope he's like playing devil's
advocate.
>> not seem to be though. It would be very
interesting to get him on the show to
have a similar walk through of his
belief system that leads him to this
conclusion. The thing that made the
cameraman walk off was he said in
reference I believe to UK, but certainly
Western Europe. Western Europe he said
over and over and over. Uh in Western
Europe
if they can't find another solution they
have to start shooting people that come
over the border illegally. He's very
clear about that. This is about illegal
immigration in Western Europe. I I
believe I've accurately represented his
statements.
>> Uh but that's pretty wild. So, he
obviously has a set of beliefs about
what the second and third order
consequences of this are going to be as
they play out over time.
You chuckled here when I mentioned his
belief. You seemed almost incredulous in
a very kind way, but you seemed very
shocked by what he was saying. So,
what's your take? Like what what happens
to
Spain? What happens to the UK as this
plays out?
I think one of the fundamental problems
is Western people specifically are
myopic and they just see the now and
that's why they look at the now and it's
like, "Ah, what's the big deal? 5% 10%
Muslims. Well, we'll figure it out
later." And the thing is it's like a
slippery slope because it keeps growing
and growing and and and the more it
grows for some reason it seems like you
know, their freedoms and the Brits for
example starts eroding because they
can't see and speak about what's
happening. And so my point is I don't
think it's too late and a lot of people
think I do. Uh I don't, but I think it's
a lot harder than you think. It's not
this isn't where oh, I'm going to vote
for this guy and now we're going to get
it done. I think that's the problem a
lot of people pin pin all their hopes on
one politician thinking you know, this
this guy's going to do a miracle and the
problem is the whole culture needs to
change. It's a paradigm shift. Okay? If
you want to actually make a change, it's
not just you can't Here's the thing, you
can't be who you are today and just
single out Islam and say goodbye.
It it be the reason Islam is becoming a
problem even though it's inherently weak
more than ever and you're inherently
strong is because of so many of the sort
of philosophies that Western the Western
epistemology has absorbed, okay? And
that's what's allowing this. So, I
believe it's going to take an actual
serious paradigm shift. It's not just
oh, we're going to create it one one or
two policies which will take care of it.
I drew for example an analogy
um you know, Rupert Lowe Yeah. and what
he's saying and you know, what he's
saying how can I go against that? I
mean, this is a man who cares about his
country, his people and he sees what's
going on. Okay, makes sense. A lot of
people like that.
But he and he's saying things like, you
know, not only are we going to stop
migration, we're going to reverse it.
And if you don't like our way of life,
you're going to leave. And I'm and a lot
of people I've heard tell me things
like, yeah, you know, we you know, we've
we've had it with Islam, we want them
all out, okay? Now here's the thing.
Stopping migration itself seems so hard
for a lot of these countries. Just that
culturally there's not the will.
>> Yeah. I mean, look at here in the United
States. Okay, it's you know, you can say
what you want to say, but as I
understand it I
and I haven't followed it, so maybe you
know, but my point is
you're an illegal alien, you don't
belong here and it supposedly as I
understand it they're going after
criminal elements. What is I mean, that
if you can't get behind that, you think
you're going to get you think the UK
which is even more liberal than America
is going to get behind
kicking Muslims out of their country?
Who've been there for years?
So, that's what I'm trying to say. It's
it's a not as easy as you know, people
can talk the talk but actually
implementing these policies and even if
you stopped all the immigration uh these
Muslim countries I've already told you
for example
Pew poll or a Pew report
said that by 2050
Germany is about to set to be 20% Muslim
and that's if migration stops. Whoa.
Which it hasn't, okay? So, I think
that's what I mean by the myopia where
again Muslims are lockstep keeping with
their the continuum of their history
which sometimes you have massive
takeovers. Um sometimes it's slow and I
I think it's very important to
understand something which might help
you and your audience which is
when I talk about Muslims the way I do,
I think you might it sounds like, man,
you're really demonizing them and
they're these evil people. Um and it's
you know, that's that's not right. I
mean, people are people and the thing is
they don't see themselves as evil.
And I'm not even saying they're evil. My
point is, they always see themselves as
the good guy. Even when they're doing
the jihad and killing and lying because
Islam is right, Islam is good, you
people are pathetic infidels, look at
the way you live. It's what God wants.
>> And we are helping bring it in any which
way we can. You know, the ends justify
the means. In their mind, they're good.
So, they're not demoralized in any way,
shape, or form.
>> Yeah. You know, you were talking about
sort of you know, it's their time. Yeah,
that's how they see it. And uh they're
doing what they're doing. Whereas the
West is so utterly demoralized. And you
know, so so defeatist, so just going out
of its way essentially to make itself
extinct by going out of its way I mean,
what kind of society you look at the UK
for example
allows Muslims to come in waving ISIS
flags, but then if you're an actual Brit
waving I don't know a St. George flag is
crazy.
>> Isn't it Think about Think about that.
That's surreal to me.
And that's the See, that's the problem.
>> you finish the sentence. You get in
trouble for waving the British flag.
That's wild. That is to me the problem.
It's not the Muslims. I've I say this
often by the way. The Muslims aren't the
issue because you know what? They're not
coming with swords and spears like they
used to. And and Europeans had to fight
them. You people always say, "Oh, UK's
being invaded." No, they're not being
invaded. You're being They're They're
being invited. You're inviting them.
This is your problem. You're doing this
to yourselves.
And I think people need to understand
that it's a much It's a much easier
message and more comforting to just Oh,
Muslims are evil and I hate them and
whine about it. And it's more It's more
I think you know, realistic to just be
kind of like whatever you think about
Islam, it's you guys who are doing this.
You are the You can look at a country
like Hungary or Poland. They don't put
up with this. They put up little fences
and they have no more problems. Okay?
And then
Hungary and Poland are not a superpower
compared to France and England, okay? Or
the UK.
So,
I think a lot of people need to
understand that it's it's
it is a problem and it is getting worse
and a lot of it has to do with you. Not
you per se, but you as a society, as a
culture. The Muslims like you're
pointing out, yeah, it's my time. I'm
doing I I
I believe in it. I'm bringing good
stuff, you know? And and they're
propelled by that.
But it's kind of like if you don't have
a anything, if you have no cultural or
any religion or heritage that you want
to that you feel is behind your
civilization, then yeah, you'll you'll
just be like an open vacuum and
something else is going to fill it.
Okay, so if we're in a position where
you've got
the UK is inviting people in.
Uh we've got this historical pattern
that repeats. We're worried about that
historical pattern cuz it tends to be
when we're weak, we're essentially
tolerant. When we get strong, we then
start forcing our religion on other
people. Um
I get that. And let's say that it played
out that way if nothing was done about
it. Why instead of a Rupert Lowe and
trying to reverse immigration and
sending everybody back, why aren't we um
really looking at the um
community the the Muslim community and
saying, "You guys need an
enlightenment." Now, I know Sam Harris
had really I think tried to go down that
road. That always resonated with me.
Um
Why can't
Islam or maybe you think it can, but um
can Islam have an enlightenment and
truly reform itself? Well, I I mean I I
the way I'm hearing it is sort of ironic
because
you or Sam Harris, Muslims don't care
what you think. And for you to come tell
them you need an enlightenment. You're
You're the enemy. You're the de facto
enemy. I already told you. You're the
infidel. So am I.
So,
forget about us telling them anything
about an enlightenment. Now, if it
organically can develop from Muslims
themselves, that's that's where it would
have to come, of course. So, basically
um
what I think is first of all, when it
comes to the word reform and here again
we go with this I think what's going on
is um
>> [snorts]
>> Western projection. You know, they think
of the Reformation, which of course is
seen as a good thing because most
Westerners are Protestants.
Is um
They
Okay, so what was the Reformation?
Mechanically, what happened technically?
What happened is you can say is
it goes on the idea of sola scriptura,
right? Which is we're done with clergy
and hierarchies in the church and you
know,
popery as it was called. And we're just
going to go with the Bible, okay?
[snorts]
So, it's me having a direct relationship
with the Bible.
>> Right. Yeah, it's uh and and and that.
Um and then when that happened, okay,
well, especially as you were saying and
you look at the New Testament, which for
Christians of course is more important.
This is the actual meaning, right? You
you find a lot of po- po- you know,
positive,
passive,
um non-hate-filled, etc., etc., okay?
Now, the the interesting thing is and
I've said this before, something of
something akin to that Reformation is
actually already happening in the
Islamic world, but it's leading to
almost a more radicalization.
Because the texts are so different. So,
I'll explain.
Islam historically
most Muslims like most Europeans were
illiterate. No one had owned a Quran. It
was just the leaders who maybe were
could read it or actually mostly they
would recite it. They memorized it by
rote. And um
so you know, you had the I told you the
scholars, they were a major role of
articulating Islam, okay? Now,
when you move to the modern or or or
like let's say now and for last century,
um the Quran Muslims are much more
literate. The Quran is now available.
It's being translated in many languages.
It's on the internet.
Even more uh
telling is the the entire corpus of the
Hadith, which is massive. The Hadith is
the recordings of what Muhammad said and
did, which is part of Islamic law
depending
>> got the writing and then we've got the
speaking. It's all there. Yeah, at
everyone's fingertips. Okay, so so it's
almost like a you know, the Protestant
thing in that Okay, the Bible's now
accessible. It's been translated.
Um
but it's leading to more radicalization
because when you if you are just your
regular Muslim and you look at some of
these texts and it says things like
Muhammad saying kill the apostate, kill
the blasphemer, wage war on the
Christian, you subjugate them.
That is prone to leading to more
radicalization. Whereas historically,
yeah, that was part of the corpus, but
the scholars put it in a in a way I
mean, you know, the hostility was there
and the war on the the infidel was part
of it, but it was a little more
systematized and a little more
pragmatic, okay? Whereas now you have
just And this is so to me the rise of
radical Muslims as they're called, they
are
they're the Muslim Protestants in the
sense that they just don't listen to any
particular cleric. They read and they
access the text themselves.
And as it happens So, how can we How can
you have the same methodology, which is
people going sola scriptura but to their
text, and yet one's religion comes out
good and one comes out bad? And this is
hard for the relativistic mindset to
understand, but it's because the texts
are very different. The bottom line is
forget about Reformation in Islam. Now,
enlightenment, that's possible. But what
an enlightenment to me what an
enlightenment means is just kind of like
All right, we've lost faith in this
religion, but we're just going to keep
it as an outer trapping because it's
part of our culture.
>> [snorts]
>> And is that possible? Maybe. Sure. I
mean,
yeah.
If Muslims collectively can do that, um
I suppose.
But I don't see that happening right now
or at any time. And again, one of the
reasons is because Muslims are
pragmatic. And when their religion is
perceived as helping empower them, they
like it. When it was seen during the
colonial era as some backward relic,
there I was watching a video for example
of
Gamal Abdel Nasser, the Egyptian
president in the '50s.
And you know, suit and tie like everyone
else.
And he makes a in in one video he It's
in Arabic. He He mocks the hijab, you
know, the what women wear. And it
everyone laughs about it.
You go to Egypt now, every every woman
is in a hijab. So, why was he and the
Egyptians like that in the '50s and all
throughout the early 20th century and in
the late 19th 19th century?
It was because they were emulating the
European colonial
colonizers who were seen as the strong
horse. And hey, we want to be like that.
We want to have what they have. We want
to When I told you about Ataturk, he's
he's the he's the paradigmatic example
of Turkey. You know, he went from Turkey
went from like I I was telling you
really this is the jihadist scourge of
Europe to being the first Muslim country
to get rid of it all and actually do
everything possible to be Westernized.
Why? Because it still had the same
impetus of wanting to be powerful. But
Islam had failed at this point. So, now
let's let's do what they're doing.
But inasmuch as the West lost its
confidence and now all it has is just
technology and and the material,
so too has it pushed Muslims back,
rightfully so or at least logically so,
to their own heritage.
Yeah. Okay, that makes a lot of sense.
Now, spinning that off into something
really tangible,
um
have you ever thought about just the raw
difference in outcomes that you're going
to get if you tell people to emulate
Jesus and if you tell them to emulate
Muhammad, who uh if I remember
correctly,
Muhammad had a um sword, a uh what is
it? A scimitar? Scimitar, yeah. Scimitar
that was named like splitter of
vertebrae Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> And good for you. When I was reading
that, I was like, "Yo!" Like
>> [laughter]
>> the So, Jesus has like all this soft
vibes. Like I'm here to be kind to
prostitutes and tip over the money
makers and help the poor people and wash
feet and forgive the guy that betrayed
me. And the other guy has a battle sword
called the splitter of vertebrae. And
it's like, damn. I [clears throat] get
why some people might be like, well,
hold on. That feels pretty dope. I've
been looked down on. I'm low class,
whatever. I want to rock with the guy
that's got the splitter of vertebrae.
And this [snorts] is actually what This
is a whole deep topic. This is actually
part of this book. But the the Jesus,
the way [clears throat] you characterize
him,
which is the way most Americans and
Christians even characterize him,
I I [snorts and clears throat] take some
umbrage with that characterization.
Um in in
not that you're wrong to say that. Of
course, Jesus is not Muhammad. Um but
there is, I think, um
if you will, I don't know I don't know
if I want to a militant side even to
Christianity, not necessarily physical,
not war, but assertive, muscular
Christianity, which I'm a I'm a firm
believer and a promoter of. That's what
this book was about, the two swords of
Christ, which is the military orders. If
you look at these guys and how they
understood Christianity, it will blow
your mind. And but they use the same
Bible and they use the same verses. It's
called two swords because for example,
Jesus said in one of the verses in in
Luke,
he maybe you know it where he says
if you don't have a sword, sell your
cloak and buy one. And the
his disciples say, Lord, look, here are
two swords. They found two swords. He
said, that's enough.
So, to your modern day Christian who
would go by the the description you gave
of Christ, that means nothing. Okay? So,
today if you if you ask an interpreter,
what does that mean? It Well, it means
nothing. He's just being parabolic or
whatever.
To the early Christians, especially
medieval Christians, what he was saying
is there are two there's two enemies in
this world. One one is a spiritual enemy
and you need a spiritual sword, which
modern day Christians I think would
agree. The other one was a was a secular
material enemy and you need a secular
sword. Okay? Which would be, for
example,
um the military arm of a society. And
that's how actually it was understood.
So, my point is and I'm going to I want
to tie this to Islam cuz that's what
we're talking about and what you just
said. But my point is in a many ways
Christianity has been emasculated and
effeminized from what it was. It wasn't
always like this. People want to think
that you know, there there's a reason
Crusaders could have existed and could
have been so ferocious and violent and
yet be more pious, believe it or not,
they were dying for their faith than
people today.
And so now let's let's go back to what
you're saying where you know, I can see
why a person would find the Muhammad
vertebrae sword kind of appealing as
opposed to I call it doormat
Christianity. This idea that you know,
Christianity is just I'm your doormat.
Come wipe your feet on me and I'm I'll
do nothing. And a lot of Western men are
either not are losing their Christianity
and even some are converting to Islam
because they find that sort of militant,
muscular, masculine side appealing. So,
I do So, on the one hand, what I'm
trying to say is there is that problem
going on today in Western nations in how
Christianity is understood. And I'm not
trying to say Christianity has jihad and
No, but there is just war. Okay? That
was something that was always long long
time ago articulated. No one had
problems with it.
But today it seems to me a lot of modern
Christians and just Western people in
general don't believe that you can't be
in any way, shape or form violence ever.
That was not at all the way they
understood it. And inasmuch as
Westerners and Christians feel that way,
it's only natural a lot of men are just
dropping out of Christianity. And it's
even more natural that a lot of them,
you know, the Andrew Tate phenomena
where you you know, they're gravitating
towards Islam because it's seen as a
patriarchal kind of masculine religion.
So, it's kind of unfortunate because
Christianity had That's what chivalry
was. Chivalry was, yeah, masculinity is
there, but we're going to tame it and
use it for righteous causes.
But without it, you know, things go
willy-nilly and you can end up with a
really toxic kind of masculinity.
Now, do you think that Western culture
at large needs to draw a line,
uh find that more masculine version of
itself to have a new reformation where
we begin reinterpreting some of the
verses in a way that that say basically
be strong, be able to wield the sword,
but keep it sheathed so that we can draw
a line and say, listen, this is our
culture and leave it Yeah. And I but I
wouldn't call it reinterpreting. I would
I would say it would be reclaiming. I
mean, that is the historic past of
Christianity. So, it's not new. It's
it's just been forgotten and jettisoned,
demonized perhaps.
Um but
yeah, it's good because it's it's used
solely for defense. You know, no
Christian I'm not saying Christianity
should go on the offense. But yeah, you
defend your world, your civilization,
your people, your family. Okay? And you
know, this goes back to illegals jumping
over, you know,
fences and whatever. Um
Christianity, there's a reason most
Christian nations up until now in the
United States will agree capital
punishment. So, I think the idea of the
problem is just too many people have um
just have come to believe that
Christianity begins and ends with
literally being a doormat. And that
actually feeds into these problems that
we're talking about even if you're not
Christian. The bottom line is if you're
not Christian, if you're an atheist, if
you're born and you kind of hinted at
this, if you're born and raised in this
Western milieu, you're going to be you
are a Christian despite yourself. Forget
about the theology, forget about the
veneer and saying I believe in Jesus and
that sort of thing. You are made and
forged by centuries of Christianity. And
to me, that's that's the more solid
thing that we're really talking about.
And when people don't realize that and
they say, no, no, like secular Western
Europe is is has nothing to do with
Christianity. Everything all the all the
things that atheists and seculars prize
is inconceivable without Christianity.
Why Why did [snorts] it come from
Europe? Humanism, you know, the
everything we talking about, tolerance
and mercy. That didn't come from
Confucius China, didn't come from Islam,
didn't come from Hinduism. Okay? There's
a reason it happened in Europe. And it's
not people Again, the fake history is
like it rose
it rose in Europe in defiance or against
Christianity. No, it actually
Christianity was the seeds because if it
was it was a matter of defiance, well,
it could have risen in the Middle East
against defiance against Islam. It could
have risen anywhere.
So, I think people need to understand
that
I personally am not very much interested
in going and telling people what to
believe theo- theologically, but I do
believe Christianity as a civilizational
cultural force is something not to be
ignored and and just discarded because
without you knowing it,
um it is really the bedrock of
everything we all like and we all love
and we want to preserve.
All the stuff that we've talked about
today, how much of your interpretation
of what is happening, what should happen
in the future is predicated on your
belief that Christianity is the word of
God and ought to be the way that
somebody lives. I'll tell you this that
I a lot of people think I'm I'm like a
hardcore Christian. I'm really not. And
it's probably cuz I write these books
you know, which deal with Christianity.
I see myself more
as a civilizational Christian, okay? Not
the not the spiritual Christian. This
doesn't mean I don't have a spiritual
life. I'm just saying that to me is more
important. But what I'll tell you is
this
that with me, if anything brought me
back to religion, it's my objective
study of history and what I'm seeing
around us today.
They are actually constantly validating
the truths of Christianity. It's not
vice versa. I think most people approach
it differently. They read
the Bible, they memorize verses or or
theological doctrines and they project
it on what's happening. I'm the
opposite. I looked at it secularly,
okay? And I I accepted it like that. But
then the more I look at it, the more it
keeps converging and coming back to
these issues about Christianity.
Um I'll tell you I'll give you a I'll
leave you with a final anecdote which is
going to amuse you, okay? So, in my
field
again, to show you how some of these
things that seem laughable, you know,
these
Christian teachings or ideas that are
superstitious and how they come back to
haunt us.
So, in the 7th century, we talked about
the Arab conquest of Christian lands.
And amongst historians today until now,
it's seen as one of the great mysteries
of history because at the time the
Arabs, 7th century, they are just an
impoverished they're described even in
their own sources as half naked, no
weapons, you know, just no
sophistication whatsoever. And then you
have the Roman Empire, which we call the
Byzantine Empire, which is still very
powerful. And you have
which is a superpower in the 7th
century. And then you have the Persians
also, which is another superpower. And
so, the mystery is how did these
Bedouins all of a sudden overrun both of
them and conquer all the land that I
told you. So, not only Persia, but all
of, you know, Christian Syria, Greater
Syria and all of North Africa and all of
Spain. That was always a mystery until
now. And there's all kinds of theories
that historians give, but they're just
conjectural. Now, what's funny to me
and I'm I know
your audience is I don't know if they're
going to like they're not going to like
this, but
but okay, they'll get a kick out of it
maybe.
What's funny to me
is that if you look at what the
Christians said of the time,
how did they rationalize this? You know,
they said they said God was punishing us
for our sins, okay? Now, I read that in
college. I wrote my thesis about, you
know, the the Islamic conquest. And it
was like your average historian, I was
like, yeah, okay, whatever. Obviously,
that's not the case, okay? That's not
why it really happened.
And the one key text that every
Christian would quote and it was written
about 690, okay? So, this is the height
of the Islamic conquest. Almost all of
North Africa is now conquered and the
Middle East and it's on the verge of
going in Spain.
It's known as the apocalypse. It was
written in Syriac and the whole thing is
yeah, God is punishing us because of
sexual immorality, because men are
dressing like women, women are dressing
like men, believe it or not.
>> No, yeah, yeah, but watch, it gets more
interesting. And this is why, okay, so
that's what it said and and that text
kept circulating and in 1683, a
millennium later when when Muslims were
besieging Vienna, they were reproducing
and publishing and disseminating it so
people understand why this is happening
because we've sinned again and sexually
immorally. Now, why I bring this up and
I find it interesting
is look at the conversation we're having
about Islam in Europe.
Islam is weaker than it's ever Okay, so
if the Muslims the the big mystery of
the 7th century is the Muslims are a lot
weaker and they beat the Romans. Let's
say they were you know, 10 times weaker
at the time.
Today, as we've just pointed out,
militarily, economically,
technologically, Europe's what? A
thousand times stronger than the Muslim
world, okay? And yet, isn't it
interesting that Muslims are such a
thorn, such a problem, taking over
Europe and whatnot? And at the same
time, there's people pointing out that
you know, if if it was because of
cross-dressing and sexual immorality, I
think there's a lot more of that today.
So, I just So, this is an example of me
telling you I read that, I didn't that
didn't convince me, but now I'm watching
reality unfold in front of me and like
yeah, things are starting to make more
sense in a way.
>> Do you think that
>> So, my So, to answer your original
question, it's not that my Christianity
colors the way, it's actually what I'm
seeing kind of makes me
validates Christianity for me.
Interesting. Let me see if I understand
that. So, there's two ways to interpret
that be if you look at it as this is a
thing that repeats throughout history
that there are these times where
we let go of conservatism, perhaps is
the right way to say it, around sexual
mores that
there's like gender bending and so
people are men are very comfortable
being effeminate, women are very
comfortable being masculine and and that
sort of sweeps, [clears throat]
whether it went all the way to where
we're at now where you know, it's a
trans phenomenon,
up in the air, but so way number one
would be that um
when a culture starts to do that, God
actually punishes you. Way number two is
that that happens at a time where your
um your culture becomes too pluripotent.
What I mean by that is when you take a
stem cell and you have a like skin cell,
let's say, and you want to make it
pluripotent so it could become anything
again. Um you you run the risk of
dedifferentiating to the point where the
the integrity of the cell begins to fall
apart. So, you have to be careful not to
turn a cell like that into a cancer cell
that just divides infinitely. Uh aging
is supposedly when you you the cells in
your body are dedifferentiating. So, an
eye cell is also sort of a heart cell,
also sort of a skin cell. And so, you
lose the like the distinctions in a
society that we have to sort of force on
people. And your society gets to a
point, I believe, because you've had
prosperity for so long, you haven't been
challenged. The thing that I always tell
people is
we need to be chased by a lion. Like we
need a difficulty, we need a threat that
forces us to have structure, to say yes
to this, no to that. And when you have
prosperity for too long, you begin to
lose that. Success seems like a natural
law of order and so you just sort of let
anything go and you're not forcing
people to be disciplined, to work hard,
to stay focused, reward meritocracy,
etc., etc. And so as almost as a physics
response to prolonged prosperity, we
find ourselves in this dedifferentiated
state and then whoever is
hyper-differentiated, believes in their
culture, has conviction to say, "Nope,
you guys are stupid. We're going to come
in and take over." That that's why those
two things may happen at the same time.
Are you saying it's God just doesn't
like it, so I'm going to you know, send
an army to take you down? Or do you
think that this is
like what I was saying, we're just sort
of is a thing that corresponds with
a problem within society? I think it
could be both, okay? And and and the I
only brought the God thing up because
you asked me directly, like how my faith
fits into this. And I was trying to give
you an example that it's not so much
that I'm I I approach it thinking about
theology. It's rather I didn't think
about theology, but then by looking at
it, it actually makes me wonder. So, I
actually didn't even finish my idea.
What I was trying to say is so, you
know, okay, so in the 7th century the
Arabs did what they did and they said
Christians said it was sexual immorality
and the Muslims or Arabs were 10 times
weaker than than Rome, so how did that
happen? That's why it's a mystery for
us. I believe, you know, a century from
now, two centuries from now, three
centuries from now the world the
posterity will look and let's say
Muslims do overrun Europe and they're
going to be like, "How did That is going
to be much greater mystery that how did
these guys who were so weak, their
countries, migrants, coming cap in hand,
poor and Europe was so powerful?" So,
that will be one of those amazing
mysteries, okay? Where people will again
be trying to come up with conjectures.
So, now put that aside. I'm just saying
I'm just trying to show you that it's
not that my religion guides me. It's if
anything, it's history is making my me
believe more in religion. But now, what
you said, of course that's that's also
just as plausible, okay? Which is you
don't have to give it a theological
explanation.
Okay,
it could be just okay, well,
I mean, what's what's that what's that
saying, you know, like strong men great
create strong societies. And then, you
know, strong societies create weak men
and weak men create weak societies, etc.
So, it's a cycle that that definitely
makes sense and you know, and and
whoever has the eye of the tiger, it's
the Muslims, they're going to want it
more. So, of course I'm not discounting
that either. Ultimately, I was just
trying to answer your question about me
and my religious lens to show you that
if anything
it's studying history and current events
that actually makes me look back and go,
"Well, yeah, that kind of makes sense
now." Not vice versa.
Where I'm forcibly applying theology.
Right. Which people do, by the way, and
I don't care for that.
Okay, for a moderate Muslim who's
watched this whole thing, they're with
us still
and they have parsed all this, but they
feel directly attacked by your
philosophies. What would you want to say
to them?
>> If this is a truly moderate Muslim, they
shouldn't feel attacked and I think they
should agree with me because they should
know, again, I've not attacked any
particular Muslim by saying, "You are
this." I've talked about a body of
beliefs and religion of a religion,
Islam. Any so-called moderate Muslim, I
can't if they were to say, "Oh, no,
you're wrong about the history or you're
wrong about Muhammad saying kill the
apostate." That's your books.
Most of this is from Muslim books that
I'm telling you, including the history.
So, [snorts] I if they're really
genuinely moderate, I think they would
agree with me and say, "Yeah, you're
right,
but I'm moderate for whatever reason.
I've rationalized it this way." If they
actually attack me, then then that's the
taqiyya Muslim. That's the one who's,
you know, playing that little game and
saying, "No, no, Islam is peace and this
guy is a liar." But and I've met a lot
of you know, a lot of Muslims who, you
know, if you want to call them moderate,
what they are is they're secular
Muslims, they're nominal Muslims,
cultural Muslims and they don't want to
break away because that's their heritage
and there's a sense of loyalty and
kinship to their people. That's it, but
they're not necessarily reading the
Quran or believing in any of that sort
of thing. And those people I would
imagine, if they heard me, if they know
anything about Islam, they would agree
quietly, secretly to themselves. So, I
don't think that should draw any ire
from them towards me.
I man, this has been incredible. Where
can people follow along with you?
Thanks. Um
well, you know, my web I have
So, my books, you can get them, they're
on my website, they're on Amazon.
I suggest if anyone's interested in in
this particular topic, Sword and
Scimitar, which this is this is the
third of a trilogy. The first one is
Sword and Scimitar and if they like
that, they can pursue them, but that one
gives you the really the general
introduction to the overall history that
we've that I barely touched on between
Islam and the West. Um and then I also
have a Substack, which people can just
look up with my name and my YouTube
channel is out there as well. What's
your YouTube channel? I think it's just
my name, but it's called the Holy War
channel because I talk about crusades
and jihads. Nice. I love it. As somebody
who's watched a lot of your content, I
highly recommend people check it out.
>> that.
>> [music]